oben werden soll nach paragraf 14 absatz
1 satz 2 des abgeordnetengesetzes
bestimme ich daher dass der dienstag 15
märz 2022 nicht als sitzungstag gilt
damit entfällt insbesondere die pflicht
sich an diesem tag in die
anwesenheitsliste
einzutragen
auf verlangen der fraktion der afg
findet heute als letzter
tagesordnungspunkt eine aktuelle stunde
mit dem thema bundeswehr einsätze in
mali beenden statt
ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 19
vereinbarte debatte zum arbeitsprogramm
2022 der europäischen kommission
für die aussprache ist eine dauer von 67
minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache
und als erste rednerin bitte ich die
staatsministerin dr anna lührmann
um das wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
europa gemeinsam stärker machen das ist
der titel des arbeitsprogramms der
europäischen kommission für 2022
europa gemeinsam stärker machen das
heißt für uns dass wir die eu reese
jenter und zukunftsfester machen wir
müssen unser europäisches haus
zukunftsfest machen
und zukunftsfest bedeutet insbesondere
klimaneutral
dieses ziel setzt sich auch das
arbeitsprogramm der eu kommission
unser europäisches haus braucht eine
klimaneutrale kernsanierung
[Applaus]
aber das wird nur gelingen wenn das
fundament unter unseren füßen stabil
bleibt
europas fundament ist artikel 2 der
europäischen verträge ausbuchstabiert
menschenwürde freiheit demokratie
gleichheit rechtsstaatlichkeit und
menschenrechte das ist es was es uns in
europa verbindet das ist es was uns von
autoritären gesellschaften unterscheidet
meine damen und herren und da gibt es
keinen interpretationsspielraum es gibt
nicht etwas menschenwürde es gibt nicht
etwas demokratie und es gibt auch keine
halben rechtsstaaten im rechtsstaat
gelten immer die gleichheit vor dem
gesetz der schutz vor staatlicher
willkür und die gewaltenteilung mit
einer unabhängigen justiz
und da wo an diesen grundsätzen
gerüttelt wird da ist nicht ein
teilaspekt des rechtsstaats gefährdet
nein da ist die demokratie als ganzes
gefährdet
wenn die rechtstaatlichkeit ist wirklich
eine zwingende voraussetzung für das
funktionieren der eu
gemeinsames handeln braucht gemeinsame
regeln und es reicht eben nicht aus nur
an die einhaltung von regeln zu erinnern
es ist auch nötig verstöße
gegebenenfalls zu ahnden und dafür ist
das urteil des europäischen gerichtshofs
vom mittwoch ein so wichtiger schritt
denn das höchste europäische gericht hat
für rechtsklarheit gesorgt
es hat gesagt der konditionalität
mechanismus ist rechtskonform
jetzt gilt in europa ein einfaches wie
wirksam das prinzip der europäisches
recht bricht der kann nicht mit
europäischem geld rechnen und im
europäischen instrumentenkasten liegt
damit ein starkes zusätzliches werkzeug
und das brauchen wir in europa ist eine
rechtsgemeinschaft und der rechtsstaats
mechanismus macht europa jetzt zu einer
wehrhaften rechtsgemeinschaft
muss jetzt zügig angewendet werden und
dabei werden wir als bundesregierung die
eu kommission nach kräften unterstützen
ich möchte bei den grundwert der
rechtsstaatlichkeit auch mit einem
missverständnis aufräumen die
auseinandersetzung um das thema in der
eu ist keine auseinandersetzung zwischen
ost und west im eurobarometer vom
letzten jahr konnten wir klar nachlesen
die mehrheit der europäerinnen und
europäer ist für für die für die
mehrheit der europäerinnen und europäer
ist die achtung der demokratie und
menschenrechte der wichtigste vorteil
der eu und zwar noch vor
wirtschaftlichen profiten das sehen auch
die ungarinnen und ungarn so ebenso die
bevölkerung polen steht klar hinter
diesen werten deshalb sind sie 1989 auf
die straße gegangen deshalb sind sie
2004 mitglied der eu geworden die frage
der rechtsstaatlichkeit meine damen und
herren keine frage der himmelsrichtung
es ist eine frage von freiheit und
demokratie
rechtsstaatlichkeit beschützt die
freiheit der rechtsstaatlichkeit
angreift der greift die demokratie an
rechtsstaatlichkeit in der europa ist
keine verhandlungssache meine damen und
herren
und damit hier kein falscher eindruck
entsteht die frage der
rechtsdurchsetzung betrifft auch uns
hier in deutschland gerade bei der
umsetzung von europäischen umweltrecht
war deutschland wahrlich kein
musterschüler in den letzten jahren
und eins muss klar sein wohlstand und
fortschritt brauchen rechts besetzung
und rechtssicherheit klimaschutz bauch
rechtsdurchsetzung in ganz europa
unternehmen brauchen rechtssicherheit
auf den binnenmarkt nur ein europa des
rechts kann auch zu einem europa des
fortschritts werden und nur durch
fortschritt werden wir das europäische
haus zukunftsfest machen vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank nächster redner für die
cdu/csu-fraktion der abgeordnete detlef
seif
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren die kommission setzt
mit der überschrift in ihrem
arbeitsprogramm
2022 sicherlich den richtigen akzent
europa gemeinsam stärker machen
schwieriger ist es dann aber dieses ziel
bei der ausgestaltung der verschiedenen
initiativen auch zu erreichen
beispiel green deal
europa soll bis 2050 zum ersten
klimaneutralen kontinent werden die
unternehmen sind bekanntlich zentraler
ort der wertschöpfung und damit auch des
wohlstands in der europäischen union
es ist überhaupt nicht geklärt für die
unternehmen wie sie die angestrebten
klimaziele tatsächlich auch erreichen
können es ist keine strategie der
europäischen union auf dem weg die genau
das in den fokus nimmt deshalb wird zu
recht von wirtschaftsverbänden wie der
vereinigung der bayerischen wirtschaft
gefordert dass die eu-kommission
wirtschaft und industrie mit derselben
entschlossenheit stärken soll wie sie
den klimaschutz voran treibt es wäre
fatal wenn am ende des
transformationsprozesses
nicht nur erfolgreiche europäische
unternehmen in die pleite getrieben
wurden sondern entgegen der planung der
eu kommission eine verlagerung der
produktion in drittstaaten stattgefunden
hätte
in der offiziellen pressemitteilung der
kommission findet sich kein wort zu asyl
und migrationspolitik im textlichen teil
des programms findet sich ein kleiner
absatz es scheint so dass die kommission
die legislativvorschläge formal zwar
weiter verfolgt diese tatsächlich aber
nur noch hinten auf der prioritätenliste
stehen bei allem verständnis für green
deal und das digitale zeitalter
die eu kommission sollte die
erforderliche reform des gemeinsamen
europäischen asylsystems des gaus mit
demselben nachdruck betreiben es handelt
sich um ein zentrales thema das keinen
aufschub gestattet wir brauchen dringend
eine verbindliche regelung um zukünftig
auszuschließen das autokratische
herrscher wie lukas schenk oder erdogan
auf die idee kommen migranten im rahmen
einer hybriden kriegsführung zu
instrumentalisieren
wir brauchen die reform des asylsystems
aber besonders um den vielfachen
missbrauch dieses schutzsystems
auszuschließen mehr als die hälfte der
menschen die formal einen asylantrag
stellen hat kein schutzanspruch die in
grants verfahren vorgesehene asyl
vorprüfung mit identifizierung und
sicherheitsprüfung würde sicherstellen
dass personen die keinen schutz anspruch
haben ermittelt werden beim dublin
system ist dringend ein
paradigmenwechsel erforderlich die
zuständigkeit zur bearbeitung von
asylanträgen
darf nicht von der geografischen lage
eines mitgliedsstaats abhängen sondern
muss fair bestimmt werden in einigen
mitgliedsstaaten herrschen unmenschliche
aufnahmebedingungen das hat im fall
griechenlands beispielsweise zur folge
dass dort bereits anerkannte
asylbewerber in deutschland erneut ein
antrag stellen können
tausende asylbewerber die anerkannt
wurden aus griechenland kommen haben
dass in der zwischenzeit genutzt und
wenn sie von rechtsstaatlichkeit reden
es ist aufgabe der kommission als
hüterin der verträge auch diese
unvertretbaren zustände schnellstmöglich
zu beseitigen
zur unterstützung der eu mitgliedstaaten
im rahmen der korona pandemie wurde
bekanntlich 2020 der ausbauplan next
generation eu geschaffen es soll sich um
ein einmaliges und um ein zeitlich
befristetes instrument handeln die
mittel sollen eine investition in die
zukunft darstellen die finanzierung
erfolgt über eu-anleihen die spätere
rückzahlung soll über sogenannte
eigenmittel erfolgen dies zurzeit aber
noch gar nicht gibt wir müssen genau
darauf achten wofür die gelder in den
mitgliedsstaaten verwendet werden sie
müssen einen investiven mehrwert haben
es ist auszuschließen dass die
mitgliedstaaten die gelder zur
allgemeinen schuldentilgung und
sanierung ihres haushalts nutzen
darüber hinaus sind die eu kommission
und die mitgliedstaaten gefordert
kurzfristig die erforderlichen
eigenmittel auf den weg zu bringen damit
letztlich nicht doch die mitgliedstaaten
haften müssen und faktisch eine
schuldenunion entsteht das wäre nicht
nur vertragswidrig sondern würde die
weitere existenz der europäischen union
aufs spiel setzen vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die spd fraktion
markus töns
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
debattieren heute das arbeitsprogramm
der kommission
und vorweg würde ich ja ich nehme
niemals gab es vielleicht einfacher zu
verstehen vorweg würde ich ganz gerne
eigentlich eine bemerkung dazu machen
die mir so ein bisschen auf der seele
brennt wir diskutieren das hier im
parlament jedes jahr weil es jedes jahr
von der kommission ein arbeitsprogramm
gibt finde das ist richtig wir
diskutieren das in den ausschüssen wir
schauen uns an was da passiert wir
machen das in den landtagen aber wir
bräuchten dazu auch eine öffentliche
debatte denn wenn wir eine größere
vertiefung der europäischen union wollen
eine politische europäische union und
die bürgerinnen und bürger mit der
europäischen union mit der kommission
debattieren wollen dann müssen wir das
auch öffentlich debattieren und ich
würde mir sehr stark wünschen dass diese
debatte auch stattfindet weil ich sie ja
ich glaube dass sie dazu beiträgt mehr
verständnis für die arbeit der
kolleginnen kollegen in der kommission
aber auch im parlament in brüssel und
straßburg zu bekommen
die eu ist liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die beste und wichtigste das
beste und wichtigste politische projekt
des vergangenen jahrhunderts und sie ist
wichtig und sie ist für uns europäer
wichtig für uns deutsche sie hat eine
zentrale bedeutung
und das ist ganz wichtig und deshalb ist
das arbeitsprogramm augen für uns auch
wichtig und dieses arbeitsprogramm fällt
jetzt in besonders schwierige zeit nicht
glaube dass wir sowieso vor uns sehr
unruhigen zeiten stehen
die pandemie ist noch nicht bewältigt
und wir sind dabei das zu tun die folgen
der pandemie werner und saft länger
belasten
arbeitsprogramm gibt darauf antworten
und ich glaube dass wir diese
diskutieren und auch darüber durchaus
mit der kommission streiten müssen aber
in diesen schwierigen zeiten fällt auch
und das will ich sehr deutlich sagen die
russlandkrise
die krise im osten europas mit der
gefahr dass ein land wie die ukraine in
einen krieg gezogen wird dass wir alle
davon betroffen sind steht außer frage
und somit haben wir und die europäische
kommission wie die europäische union
auch eine verantwortung ihr volk
aber diese verantwortung und wenn wir
mit den osteuropäischen staaten geben
und über verantwortung sprechen dann hat
das auch viel mit unserer eigenen
verantwortung zu tun vor dem rechtsstaat
und deshalb ist das schon vorhin
zitierte von der ministerin zitierte
rechts der rechtsstaats mechanismus und
das ogh-urteil das urteil des
europäischen gerichts auch von zentraler
bedeutung
dass hier klar gemacht wurde dass
sanktionen möglich sind wir haben eine
verantwortung dafür rechtsstaat
pressefreiheit die rechte von
minderheiten und menschenrechte sind
schlichtweg nicht verhandelbar und schon
gar nicht in einer demokratischen
europäischen union
und wenn wir von einer wertegemeinschaft
reden und von gemeinsamen werten dann
lassen sie mich eines dazu sagen wer in
europa davon träumt eine liberale
demokratie zu schaffen die muss gesagt
sein dass das mit uns nicht zu machen
ist denn das ist keine demokratie
das hat mit demokratie überhaupt nichts
zu tun
und an der stelle für einige die auch
gerne mal dazwischen rufen vielleicht
man zitat sie haben vielleicht den
bundespräsidenten zugehört der hat ja
für ihn gerne zitieren herrn steinmeier
gesprochen von der verantwortung meine
verantwortung gilt allen menschen in
unserem land überparteilich werde ich
sein ja aber nicht neutral wenn es um
die sache der demokratie geht wer für
die demokratie streitet hat mich auf
seiner seite wer sie angreift wird mich
als gegner haben und das gilt für uns
alle in diesem land dass wir uns um die
demokratie nicht nur in europa in der
europäischen union sondern darüber
hinaus kümmern und das ist eine aufgabe
zentrale aufgabe der europäischen union
und gerade von uns deutschen
aber lassen sie mich noch einige
anmerkungen machen zu dem
arbeitsprogramm es geht hier vor allem
darum dass wir ein stabiles europa haben
mit geregelten auch handelsbeziehungen
die eu hat 46 abkommen mit 78 partnern
das zeigt schon dass wir da eine
herausragende rolle spielen und das ist
europäische kompetenz die war die
handelsverträge zu machen das heißt je
begleiten sie und wir sollten da sehr
genau darauf achten denn worum geht es
zukünftig es geht darum dass wir auf
europäischer ebene schaffen mit unserem
partner eine reform die wto
hinzubekommen der jetzige zustand der
wto ist nicht ist nicht in einem zustand
in dem wir uns das wünschen würden wir
brauchen eine vertiefung der
partnerschaft der eu mit nachbarstaaten
das ist auch wichtig
unter anderem mit den erweiterungs
ländern aber auch mit den ländern in
afrika ich bin froh dass die
französische ratspräsidentschaft
afrika in den fokus wieder nimmt das ist
zentral für uns
dieses ist sind alles wichtige aspekte
und es ist auch eine
ambitionierte strategie damit umzugehen
dafür dürfen aber nicht vergessen dass
wir auch schon abgeschlossene oder in
der abschluss befindliche
handelsverträge haben merken suhr und
auch sieht was demnächst wahrscheinlich
durch das verfassungsgericht geurteilt
wird zum schluss will ich ihnen nur noch
eines sagen die neuausrichtung der
handelsstrategie ist ein wichtiger
schritt und er hat effektive
nachhaltigkeits standards und
streitbeilegung mechanismen zu
berücksichtigen und aus meiner sicht
ganz wichtig es wird gute
funktionierende internationale hat
handels netzwerke sicher nicht nur um
unseren wohlstand zu sichern und unseren
frieden sondern auch die werte der
europäischen union dafür streiten wir
alle zumindest die demokraten in diesem
haus vielen dank und glückauf
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die afg fraktion dr
harald weil der kollege spricht von oben
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin damen und herren hier
und außerhalb auch diese kommission ist
nicht hüterin sondern über den er in und
aus höheren nicht nur der europäischen
idee im allgemeinen sondern selbst der
europäischen verträge im besonderen sie
steht zusammen mit dem sogenannten
europäischen parlament ministerrat und
trat für eine einzigartige
selbstreferenzielle anti
subsidiaritätsrüge zum ersten und
hoffentlich nicht letzten mal hat man
lediglich 1999 jahren endlich mal eine
kommission komplett nach hause geschickt
möge sich dies in bälde wiederholen zur
begründung erst mal ein eu.com
selbstzitat die europäische kommission
hat auf alle herausforderungen prompt
reagiert sie hat der chor witt 19
pandemie einhalt geboten ist gegen die
auswirkungen der klima und umweltkrise
vorgegangen punkt punkt punkt gestatten
wir uns ein lächeln
vorgegangen wird jedoch vor allem gegen
die wirtschaftlichen kulturellen und
insbesondere freiheitlichen interessen
der gesamten eu bevölkerung und
insbesondere der bevölkerungs und
berufsgruppen außerhalb des künstlichen
brüsseler füllhorns in nahezu jedem
eu-land könnte man besser leben blieben
die nationalen talente zu hause in
produktiven ja kreative tätigkeiten
anstatt sich als brüsseler wunsch welt
architekt oder schein baustellen
hilfsarbeiter für wolkenkuckucksheim
architektouren zu verdingen
der ideologischen volks erziehung der
jeweiligen landes oder staatsregierung
fügt sich die kommission als weitere
möchtegern aufeinander hinzu sie geriert
sich nicht etwa als dienstleisterin für
notwendiges sondern eher als
hohepriesterin für überflüssiges bis hin
zum höchst schädlichen in nahezu allen
kardinal punkten agiert sie als bloß
subunternehmerin globalisierter
interessenpolitik im bewährten panik
modus von klima und corona aber noch ist
die korona welle nicht zuende geritten
jetzt soll sogar auf vorschlag des
ratspräsidenten michelle der brüsseler
nicht der deutschen shell es hier
gemeint dass whu super bürokraten joint
venture eines weltgesundheits rates aus
der retorte gezaubert werden dazu nur
kurz anstatt mit 194 staaten von denen
lediglich ein paar dutzend leidlich
funktionieren sollte man doch lieber mal
weltweit ein verbot der
vuvuzela function forschung durchsetzen
nach dem muster der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde zb und ein
interinstitutionelle seoul ethik gremium
auch eu ethik behörde genannt von der
bundesregierung braucht das nicht denn
man sieht ja wie man sich schon
hierzulande von dem selbst installierten
ethikrat und ähnlichem die
fragwürdigsten vorhaben und
unsachgemäßen rein politischen
entscheidungen absegnen lässt
atomausstieg impfzwang usw weitere
fadenscheinige selbst selbst und schein
legitimierung braucht es dann nun
wirklich nicht zumal sich doch höchste
gerichte dafür ein ums andere mal herbei
lassen und auch für ethik fragen
scheinen doch am ende interpol europol
olaf ihr ist jetzt nicht der
bundeskanzler gemeint sowie die
nationale rechtspflege die weit besseren
und finalen adressen zu sein ob nun in
der analogen oder digitalen welt und
verschenkt wird bei alledem von brüssel
rein gar nichts ich zitiere besondere
aufmerksamkeit wollen wir dabei der
jungen generation schenken daher der
vorschlag für das europäische jahr der
jugend auch dieses freibier steht bei
jemand auf der rechnung
auslandsreisen und fremdsprachen sind
für viele seit kindesbeinen doch
standardprogramm der hippen
spaßgesellschaft eine
zusatzqualifikation die ohnehin fast ein
jeder hat ich komme zum schluss aber
wenn es bei der ruf litt beruflichen
karriere durch oder mit eu ropa dann
eben nicht nur um aller welt bachelor
oder master gerade geht sondern um den
nationalen pass spricht den eu
verwaltungs national proporz dann wird
der großteil der nettozahler landjugend
schlagartig klar werden dass sie nicht
nur den kontraproduktiven brain drain
der vermeintlich schwächeren länder
beförderten sondern dafür auch noch mit
dem eigenen karriere verzicht im inland
wie im ausland bezahlten denken sie mal
darüber nachdenke
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die fdp fraktion
ist die abgeordnete katja adler die ich
hier ganz herzlich zu ihrer ersten rede
im deutschen bundestag begrüßt
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
europa gemeinsam stärker machen unter
dieses motto hat die europäische
kommission ihr arbeitsprogramm gestellt
und mit themen wie dem europäischen
green deal europa in digitalen zeitalter
angepasst dass karl regeln einer
globalen steuer reform die schaffung
einer echten europäischen verteidigung
sony ohne die stärkung unserer
demokratie und förderung unserer
europäischen lebensweise hat sich die
europäische kommission viel vorgenommen
doch gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern und freunden werden wir als
fortschritt koalition die europäische
union fit für die zukunft machen
herzstück der europäischen integration
ist der gemeinsame europäische
binnenmarkt den wir nun nach fast 29
jahren in die digitale zukunft führen
müssen der dritte markets act und
erwitte service pack dürfen hier nur der
anfang sein sein gemütlich mit
ermöglichen wir unseren unternehmern
erfinderinnen und erfinder nein
rechtlichen rahmen für ihre innovation
zb durch die harmonisierung der
mobilfunklizenz versteigerung oder die
schaffung von freiraum für künstliche
intelligenz
stabile stattfinden für uns liberale
seit jeher das tragende fundament
unserer sozialen marktwirtschaft des
stabilitäts und wachstumspaktes in
europa wichtigster grund für alle einer
nachhaltigen politik als ampelkoalition
sind wir uns einig dass wir den pakt
weiterentwickeln und vereinfachen müssen
denn 100 seiten anleitung für zwei da
eigentlich ganz einfache regeln von
reform zu reform ist der stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt
unübersichtlicher in transparenter und
komplizierter geworden nicht nur das
zeigt dass die europäische union im
bereich bürokratieabbau stärker werden
muss
überbordende demokratische wege als
innovations- hemmer nicht nur in
deutschland ist das ein problem
deshalb freut es mich besonders dass die
kommission nun endlich das prinzip
worden in one out anwenden will wir
freien demokraten dann besonders darauf
achten dass innovation unbürokratisch
und unkompliziert möglich werden bauen
wir türme aus ideen statt stapeln aus
papier und
unsere freiheit und der pluralismus der
medien sind essentielle grundlagen
unserer demokratischen systeme der plan
der europäischen kommission einen
europäischen rechts aktion
medienfreiheit vor zudem kommt
angesichts neuerlicher entwicklung keine
sekunde zu früh
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen lassen
sie mich an dieser stelle an unseren
freund und ehemaligen außenminister
guido westerwelle erinnern der einmal
gesagt hat europa hat seinen preis aber
es hat auch sein wert und dieser wert
verehrte kolleginnen kollegen geht weit
über das ökonomische hinaus dieser wert
wird deutlich bei über einer million
lasst uns babys die zeigen dass liebe
nicht vor grenzen haltmacht
neben will den menschen die möglichkeit
ihren beruflichen erfolg ihr glück und
ihre liebe in europa zu finden
verbessern wir die anerkennung der
elternschaft über die grenzen der
mitgliedstaaten hinaus
nicht nur in deutschland sehen wir dass
die gesellschaft in ihrer inneren
liberalität das gelten familienrecht
bereit weit überholt hat deshalb hat
sich die ampel koalition in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag auf eine umfassende
reform des familienrechts verständigt
familie ist da wo füreinander
verantwortung übernommen wird und das
europaweit
wirken wir also gemeinsam darauf hin
dass unterschiedliche familien vom
europaweit anerkannt werden und öffnen
wir endlich den europäischen raum für
freizügigkeit für diese familie die
kommission hat 2022 zum europäischen
jahr der jugend erklärt lassen sie uns
nun gemeinsam das mit leben füllen
beispielsweise durch die stärken von all
das muss plus und die schaffung von
austauschmöglichkeiten für auszubildende
kommen sie liebe zum jazz und kollegen
wir alle sind europa in diesem sinne
machen wir das beste draus machen wir
europa stärker und machen wir europas
unser aller erfolg vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion die
linke alexandra alexander ulrich
guten morgen frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in diesen
stunden takt ja in brüssel der eu afrika
gipfel und ich glaube diesen deutlichen
ausdruck bringen europa und auch
deutschland
wir waren kleine keinen preis sind keine
guten partner während der korona krise
es ist unsolidarisch ist eine schande
wie bei den afrikanischen kontinent im
stich lassen südafrikas regierungschef
hat gesagt es herrsche impfstoff
apartheid deshalb auch hier an die
bundesregierung und an auch die die
gipfel teilnehmer aus europa geben sie
endlich die impfstoffe frei afrika
braucht diese und der können corona
nicht in europa besiegen sondern nur
weltweit und auch in anbetracht
die korona krise hat die europäische
wirtschaft in große schwierigkeiten
gebracht und man hat fehler die man in
der finanz und wirtschaftskrise gemacht
hat zum glück nicht wieder erholt und
hat schon sehr früh im frühjahr 2020 den
stabilitäts- und wachstumspaktes carl
regeln ausgesetzt weil man gewusst hat
wir können diesen wirtschaftlichen
einbruch nur begegnen wenn wir auch als
staaten kräftig dagegen an investieren
und ich glaube wir werden in europa
nicht bei dem stand ankommen wie jetzt
wenn wir diese möglichkeit nicht gehabt
hätten gegen die sozialen niedergang
gegen die wirtschaftliche niedergang da
auch vieles zu tun wir wissen selbst in
deutschland wie viel geld hier dafür in
die hand nehmen bis heute noch deshalb
ist vollkommen falsch jetzt schon wieder
zurückzukehren zu den regeln des
stabilitäts- und wachstumspakt deshalb
begrüßen wir ausdrücklich dass
frankreich und italien den stabilitäts
und wachstumspakt reformieren wollen wir
brauchen auch in zukunft für die
sozial-ökologische
information für die krise
genveränderungen die die notwendig sind
um die klimaziele zu erreichen handelnde
staaten europa und deshalb hoffe ich
dass die bundesregierung nicht auf die
fdp hört die relativ schnell wieder
zurückkehren will wir brauchen in
zukunft investitionen in ganz europa und
dafür braucht zumindest damit wollten
wir regel dass diese investitionen nicht
bei die verschuldungskriterien mitzählen
man kann aber auch in europa darüber
nachdenken wenn man sich verschulden
will lieber fdp damit kann man ja auch
mal hingeht kann star wie kann man die
einnahmeseite erhöhen wir verbrauchen
wir natürlich auch europaweite
vermögensabgabe wir brauchen europa
endlich die digital steuer und was ist
eigentlich aus der
finanztransaktionssteuer geworden wir
haben damals klipp und klar gesagt auch
die finanzjongleure sollen mithelfen
diese krisen zu bezahlen bis zum
heutigen tag ist keine
finanztransaktionssteuer umgesetzt
worden obwohl sie sogar schon damals der
finanzminister schäuble schon mal im
haushalt eingeplant habe sie haben mal
wieder von den börsen und finanzmärkten
sind eingeknickt wir brauchen aber diese
steuer und mir war das linke immer
wieder darauf hinweisen
viele
hochglanzbroschüren der europäischen
kommission und auch der zukunftsgipfel
und alles was da geplant ist wird nur
dann erfolgreich sein wenn die
europäischen bürgerinnen und bürger
einen mehrwert durch europa erfahren und
deshalb kann es nicht sein dass das
soziale europa das alles immer nur auf
sonntagsreden diskutiert wird sondern
auch tatsächlich auch praktische
umsetzungen deshalb muss in diesem jahr
die richtlinie für europäische
mindestlöhne endlich zum erfolg geführt
werden und das muss auch so sein dass es
auch handballer ist das auch umgesetzt
wird wir sagen als linke 60 prozent dass
billy an lohnt in jedem land das der
würde portugal anders sein als in
deutschland aber wir brauchen endlich
verbindliche untergrenzen in ganz europa
und nicht nur als empfehlungen sondern
auch durchsetzbar das braucht europa
schon werden wir die menschen nicht mehr
mit gewinnen allerletzten jetzt die
europäische kommission kommt ja immer
wieder aufständische vorschläge nicht
nur dass sie kurz vor weihnachten
silvester wer welcher beamte auch in
düsseldorf kurz vor mitternacht die
taxonomie durch geleitet hat das aber
komisch jetzt in zukunft mit die
taxonomie aufgenommen wird diese doch
sind sie jetzt mit dem glorreichen
vorschlag gekommen dass man in zukunft
aufrüstung von der mehrwert-
steuerbefreiung soll
grundnahrungsmittels werden besteuert
aber rüstungsgüter sollen von der steuer
befreit werden solch ein europa braucht
niemand vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen dr anton hofreiter
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
anna lührmann hat bereits darauf
hingewiesen dass große bedeutung die
rechtsstaatlichkeit und das urteil von
mittwoch für die europäische union für
die demokratie hat aber ich glaube man
muss sich sehr bewusst sein dass dieses
urteil auch eine große bedeutung hat für
die möglichkeit der europäischen union
nach außen herein und stark aufzutreten
nämlich nur wenn wir nach innen
glaubwürdig unsere rechtsstaatlichkeit
verteidigen und erhalten und dort wieder
ausbauen wo sie bereits in großen
schwierigkeiten ist sind wir in der lage
stark nach außen aufzutreten
und wenn man sich die lage in der welt
anschaut und da geht es nicht nur um die
vom adresse russland verursachte krise
in osteuropa im moment sondern auch um
herausforderungen durch die klimakrise
um herausforderungen durch ökonomisch
sehr erfolgreich aber autoritär und
immer diktatorische auftretende regime
in china dann brauchen wir ein starkes
gemeintes souveränes und
handlungsfähiges europa
und um ein starkes geeintes des
handlungsfähiges europa zu bekommen
brauchen wir die einigkeit und die
handlungsfähigkeit und die pro
europäischen kurs der großen
mitgliedstaaten es gibt ein bekanntes
bonmot in europa es gibt nur zwei
staaten von ländern innerhalb der
europäischen union kleine länder und
länder die noch nicht begriffen haben
dass die kleine länder sind angesichts
der herausforderungen
durch china durch russland und deshalb
ist es entscheidend dass wir mit aller
kraft mit aller kraft uns als neue
regierung einbringen für ein geeintes
europa und
deshalb ist es auch wichtig dass man
gegenüber kinder nicht mehr naiv
auftritt und deshalb ist es entscheidend
dass das außenministerium und die neue
bundesregierung eine kohärente neue
kinder strategie voran bringt man denke
daran recht schwere fehler in der
vergangenheit gemacht worden sind man
hat damals in der banken- und
finanzkrise
griechenland das sicheren großen
schwierigkeiten war und auch selber
schwere fehler gemacht weil auch von
seiten der deutschen bundesregierung
unter druck gesetzt einen der
wichtigsten mittelmeer hafen piräus an
china zu verkaufen
welch schwerer
geostrategischer fehler
jahrelang stand man mit einer mischung
von verblüffung und desinteresse vor der
strategie der neuen seidenstraße
der chinesischen regierung und die ist
da bereits weit vorgedrungen
und deshalb ist es ganz entscheidend
dass darauf ankommt dass wir als neue
regierung die strategie der europäischen
union global gateway massiv unterstützen
denn
ein kinder ist natürlich wenn es im
kampf gegen die klimakrise geht
wichtiger partner für uns china es
aber auch unglaublich
herausfordern der wettbewerber und wenn
es um frage von demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit geht das system
rivale und darauf müssen wir mit einer
mischung aus klugheit und
selbstbewusstsein agieren und deshalb
ist auch entscheidend dass in
zusammenarbeit mit den afrikanischen
ländern von den vielen versprechungen
die in der vergangenheit gemacht worden
sind zukünftig deutlich mehr umgesetzt
wird und auch da habe ich große hoffnung
in den neuen bundeskanzler um mit einer
neuen außenministerin dass da einiges in
der realität umgesetzt wird deshalb die
herausforderungen sind groß aber mit
einem geeinten souveränen und
handlungsfähigen europa sind wir in der
lage sie erfolgreich umzusetzen gehen
wir sie an vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
dr christoph plus
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen wie können wir als europäer
gegenüber großmächten wie china russland
den usa mithalten und eine rolle spielen
was können wir tun damit der
industriestandort europa gestärkt wird
und europäische unternehmen auf dem
weltmarkt wettbewerbsfähig sind das sind
entscheidende fragen auf die wir
antworten geben müssen hier im deutschen
bundestag
wenn ich mir die reden gerade von den
kollegen der ampelkoalition anhöre dann
höre ich das hohelied auf den
multilateralismus dann höre ich den ruf
nach einer gemeinsamen europäischen
außenpolitik und das ist im grundsatz
richtig nur ihre botschaften harmonieren
nicht mit ihrem politischen handeln
schauen wir doch mal auf den ukraine
russland konflikt da hat sich die ampel
koalition komplett von allen partnern
der nato von den europäischen partnern
entfernt einen deutschen alleingang
hingelegt und dafür gesorgt dass unser
ansehen gerade gegenüber osteuropa in
den letzten wochen massiv gesunken ist
die ersten die ersten wollen waffen an
die ukraine liefern damit die ukraine
sich gegen eine mögliche weitere
russische invasion verteidigen kann und
was macht die ampelkoalition sie
untersagt dass olaf scholz nimmt neben
dem us präsidenten joe biden das wort
nord stream zwei nicht mal in den mund
obwohl der us-präsident genauso wie alle
anderen europäischen partner ein klares
signal sich wünschen nord stream zwei
bis gestorben wenn die russen in die
ukraine einmarschieren und weitere teile
annektieren und wenn ich mir dann
wenn ich mir dann noch obendrauf das
handeln der spd der führenden
regierungspartei bei dem russland
konflikt anschaue da muss ich sagen
blamiert und auch das gegenüber allen
partnern in der welt wir haben wir haben
wir haben olaf scholz der teilweise
wochenlang nahezu untergetaucht ist wir
haben wir haben kevin kühnert wir haben
kevin kühnert der auch noch teilweise
negative von putin hier verbreitet im
deutschen fernsehen völlig nach eine
völlig neue außenpolitische haltung an
den tag legt und wir haben eine wir
haben personen wie manuela schwesig die
auch noch die amerikaner in dieser phase
attackieren und die eine nibelungentreue
zu russland an den tag legen die uns
gerade im nato-bündnis und innerhalb der
europäischen union massiv schadet und
und friedrich merz friedrich merz hat es
vor zwei wochen hier im deutschen
bundestag
hervorragend auf den punkt gebracht er
hat gesagt angesichts dieser aggression
von russland da brauchen wir keinen euro
keinen deutschen alleingang sondern wir
brauchen eine gemeinsame europäische
antwort die wir auch mit allen
europäischen partnern abstimmen müssen
meine damen und herren
und wenn wir wenn wir das feld der
außenpolitik verlassen es gibt ja noch
ganz viele felder über die wir hier in
dieser debatte sprechen müssen schauen
wir mal auch die industrie politik auch
da hat die ampel in den ersten wochen
ihres handelns ein klaren fehlstart
hingelegt gerade von der fdp war
erwartet worden dass sie
technologieoffene ansätze unterstützt
damit europäische unternehmen
klimaneutral werden können damit
europäische unternehmen im weltweiten
wettbewerb eine antwort geben können wie
sie ihre prozesse klimaneutral gestalten
und alle unternehmen in deutschland auch
alle in europa sind im prinzip bereit
diesen weg zu gehen die wollen
investieren die wollen aber politische
rahmenbedingungen die für alle
klimafreundlichen technologien gleiche
rahmenbedingungen zulassen für
wasserstoff für klimaneutrale
kraftstoffe wie es für batterien was
macht die ampel sie zerstreitet sich in
der regierung es gibt einen wettbewerb
zwischen den grünen und der fdp die
grünen sagen man soll lazio nur auf
batterien setzen gerade im pkw sektor
und die fdp kann sich an die
wahlversprechen erinnern mit der folge
dass unsicherheit herrscht und das
notwendige investition in klimaneutrale
kraftstoffe in wasserstoff ausbleiben
dass gerade die deutsche flugzeug
industrie dass die flugzeugbauer drohen
zurückzufallen denn wenn man sich
anschaut die usa die sind da viel weiter
die investieren in klimaneutrale
kraftstoff und die geben eine gemeinsame
antwort deswegen kann ich nur sagen wir
werden druck machen dass wir eine
gemeinsame europäische antwort als
bundesrepublik deutschland mit unseren
partnern geben wir werden druck machen
dass technologieoffenheit auch in europa
fest verankert ist und wir werden druck
machen dass sie endlich international
kooperieren anstatt unser land mit
nationalen alleingängen zu blamieren
herzlichen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die spd fraktion
jörg nürnberger den ich auch zu seiner
ersten rede hier im hause gewesen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich möchte mich
nach diesen rundumschlag meines kollegen
wieder auf das arbeitsprogramm der
europäischen kommission für die nächste
dieses jahr konzentrieren sich dabei auf
zwei themen beschränken und zwar die
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
sowie die zusammenarbeit in den
grenzregionen
meine auswahl ist darin begründet dass
ich selbst seit mehr als 25 jahren in
drei eu staaten als anwalt tätig bin und
in zwei ländern leben und damit
sozusagen hautnah live und in farbe
miterleben welche erwartungen die
menschen in deutschland aber auch in
tschechien oder österreich an die
politik der eu haben
innerhalb der eu wird immer häufiger die
frage gestellt was der beitrag der
europäischen union zur stärkung ihrer
äußeren sicherheit sein kann es ist
deshalb zu begrüßen dass zeitnah mit dem
sogenannten strategischen kompass eine
neue grundlage für die
sicherheitspolitische zusammenarbeit
geschaffen wird es geht aber auch ein
vielfältiges instrumentarium zivil und
militärisch ich konnte mich bei einem
besuch des multinationalen kommandos der
eu in ulm davon überzeugen dass hier
soldatinnen und zivile mitarbeiterinnen
aus allen teilen der eu ganz
hervorragend zusammenarbeiten um
internationale einsätze vorzubereiten
diese umsetzung der strategie wird zu
mehr sicherheit in europa führen und
gibt den menschen insbesondere auch in
unseren östlichen nachbarstaaten die
bestätigung dass sich zusätzlich zur
nato auch die eu um ihre berechtigten
und unsere gemeinsamen
sicherheitsinteressen kümmern werden
es liegt in unserem eigenen interesse
und wir sind es auch den menschen
schuldig die frau staatsministerin hat
es zu beginn erwähnt die sich vor 30
jahren für unseren gemeinsamen für den
freiheitlichen weg entschieden haben
eine voraussetzung für eine konsequente
und gemeinschaftliche sicherheitspolitik
nach außen ist auch die stärkung des
inneren zusammenhalts in der
europäischen union und wo könnte man das
besser sehen als in den grenzregionen
zwischen den einzelnen mitgliedstaaten
genau so eine region darf ich hier als
abgeordneter vertreten mein wahlkreis
liegt die neue regel grenze ist die
teile sachsens thüringens bayerns und
westböhmen miteinander verbindet hier
wird seit 30 jahren ein wertvoller
beitrag zu ganz praktischen
zusammenarbeit in europa geleistet
grenzüberschreitende rettungsdienst
gemeinsame landesplanung ein gast
schuljahren vieles mehr sind beispiele
dafür die korona bedingten
grenzschließungen haben den
gegenseitigen beziehungen schweren
schaden zugefügt es freut mich daher
wenn jetzt die stärkung der
zusammenarbeit die verbesserung der
kommission sowohl auf seiten der eu wie
auch im programm der französischen
ratspräsidentschaft und ebenfalls im
koalitionsvertrag einen wichtigen raum
einnimmt
die menschen in den grenzregionen stehen
in ihrer ganz überwiegende mehrheit zu
einer vertiefung zum ausbau der
beziehungen und am ende der rede möchte
ich ein ganz kleines aber sehr
persönliches beispiel darstellen und
verdeutlichen was es mir geht vor
einigen jahren kann man damals
achtjährige sohn auf mich zu und stellt
die mir die folgende frage
aber sag mal ich habe eine tschechische
mama und ich habe einen deutschen pop
bin ich jetzt eigentlich mehr tscheche
oder mehr deutsche meine antwort darauf
war jonas das ist doch ganz einfach
wenn wir fußball spielen ist natürlich
deutschland es ist klar wenn du über
eishockey reden darfst du gerne
tschechisch seien
zwei große sehr unglaubliche kinderaugen
haben mich angeschaut und stellten dann
die frage was meinst du das jetzt
wirklich ernst oder
ich habe die augen brauchen etwas nach
oben gezogen darauf geantwortet
es ist eigentlich völlig unerheblich
solange wir in einem freiheitlichen
europa mit guten sozialen und
ökologischen standards leben oder
überall wohnen studieren und arbeiten
kannst spielen deine beiden
staatsangehörigkeiten keine
entscheidende rolle wir als spd-fraktion
werden wir uns dafür einsetzen die
zusammenarbeit in der eu zu stärken
sodass nicht nur mein kleiner europäer
sondern allen jungen menschen in der us
in der eu eine sichere zukunft geboten
werden kann wir als spd-fraktion finden
das sehr gut vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion
norbert kleinwächter
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen ich bin mir
sicher erst wenn getestet wird zeigen
sich geist und seele wahrhaftig ganz und
gar nicht selbst verliebt zitiert sich
ursula von der leyen da selbst ganz zu
beginn des arbeitsprogramms und sie
wissen ja vielleicht ich bin lehrer
damit mit der natur von tests wird raus
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen diese
frau hat keine ahnung diese frau hat
keine ahnung test sind kein selbstzweck
sie verweisen auch nicht auf eine
größere wahrheit sondern sie sollen
kenntnisse und fähigkeiten evaluieren
vielleicht feststellen wo man noch
nacharbeiten muss auf gut deutsch ob der
schüler was gelernt hat und die
kommission muss ich feststellen hat nix
gelernt sie lernt nicht die fakten sie
lernt nicht aus den eigenen fehlern und
sie lernt nicht aus den fehlern der
anderen
es ist wirklich schon grotesk mit
welchem eifer die die eu-kommission
konzepte kopiert die woanders
gescheitert sind zb in der eu es agenda
für den globalen wandel ja in den usa
heißt das ding ja green new deal ist
abgelehnt worden in der eu heißt es
european green deal und dort will man
die gesellschaft gewaltsam
transformieren zu irgendwas ökologischen
und einem einer union der gleichheit
nein liebe kollegen von der
linksfraktion das hatten sie nie gedacht
in der internationalen sozialistischen
vereinigung dass sogar die eu kommission
sie mal links überholte unter gleichheit
und es passiert dann auch mit programmen
wie bloomberg bei beiden auch
gescheitert in der eu will man gleichen
bild berg better world machen also dass
man wieder die ganze welt beglücken so
ein saftiges rückbau programm was in den
elfenbeintürmen von un oecd und weltbank
entwickelt worden ist das wird ganz
bestimmt gut ankommen bei den würde
meine damen und herren das ist wirklich
ein charaktermerkmal mittlerweile der eu
kommission dass sie in gebieten
unterwegs in denen sie absolut nichts zu
suchen hat corona ist ein beispiel da
fühlt sie sich dass sie ein zertifikat
entwickelt hat mit dem man millionen
bürger der freiheit aussperrt da rühmt
sich damit dass sie 4,6 milliarden
impfdosen irgendwie bestellt hat das
sind 10 pro bürger kein wunder diese
politik hält man ja nur noch an der
nadel aus sie wäre in der
migrationspolitik mitreden zivil
milliarden deutscher steuergelder
verschwenden und sie will sogar eine
strategie zur pflege und bildung haben
von säugling bis zum greis da kann man
auch nur noch laut rufen nein wir wollen
das nicht demokratie bedeutet
selbstbestimmung und deswegen muss man
rufen eu raus
aber wer aufmuckt herr petri den trifft
natürlich die volle härte des
rechtsstaatlichkeit mechanismus
vertragsverletzungsverfahren droht die
eu-kommission ganz offen an und da muss
man ganz einfach nur zu den bürgern
sagen uns stehen glaube ich harte
prüfungen bevor und die erkenntnis für
viele das ist ein schwerer fehler war
nicht die afg zu wählen diese hatte die
wahrheit gesagt und hätte viel leid
verhindert
meine damen und herren geist und seele
werden nicht wahrhaftig in tests sondern
eher entsprechen und im handeln und es
ist wahrlich unfreiwillig komisch dass
die eu-kommission sogar eine initiative
zur abwanderung hochqualifizierter
arbeitskräfte auflegt kein wunder vor
dieser kommission kann man nur noch die
flucht ergreifen vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
konrad stockmeier den ich auch zu seiner
ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag begrüßt
verehrte frau präsidentin geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen und
selbstverständlich meine damen und
herren zu hause in mannheim
kleinwechter in richtung in richtung der
alternative für destruktive kann ich nur
anmerken dass man das zitat der
kommissionspräsidentin dass sie dem
arbeitsgericht vorangestellt hat erst
wenn man getestet wird zeigen sich geist
und seele wahrhaftig dass man dieses
zitat natürlich auch konstruktiv
interpretieren kann und aus ihm die
frage ableiten kann welche
schlussfolgerungen denn aus dem test zu
ziehen sind denen diese pandemie
zweifellos auch für die europäische
union darstellt
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
stellt auf die widerstandsfähigkeit der
eu staaten eben als union ab angesichts
der großen herausforderungen unserer
zeit und daher möchte ich aus aktuellem
anlass an dieser stelle anmerken dass es
aus sicht der freien demokraten in der
tat keine rabatte auf
rechtsstaatlichkeit für umgang und polen
geben darf der ogh hat in seinem urteil
dem rechtsstaats mechanismus bestätigt
fordern die kommission auf diesen nun
auch zur anwendung zu bringen denn die
grundwerte der eu sind nicht
verhandelbar
die widerstandsfähigkeit der
europäischen union wird wachsen wenn die
kommission in der tat auch den grundsatz
der subsidiarität
stark beherzigt und sich andererseits
auch darauf fokussiert wo sie die großen
herausforderungen unserer zeit
supranational angehen kann wo wir
gemeinsam eben als mitgliedstaaten
stärker agieren als individuell
lassen sie mich kurz aus dem
arbeitsprogramm einige aspekte zum
themenkomplex klimaschutz und energie
heraus greifen die fdp fraktion steht
zum fit fifty five programm dabei ist es
uns besonders wichtig dass die maßnahmen
und die zielvorgaben in der tat
technologie offen gestaltet werden und
kollege plus erlauben sie mir die
anmerkung ich weiß nicht was sie so in
hamburg machen schauen sie mal bei
airbus vorbei die sind längst an
alternativen antrieben dran der ausflug
könnte sich lohnen
denn wir brauchen nicht nur den ausbau
von windkraft und photovoltaik und neue
leitungen und netze wir brauchen auch
weitere formen der erneuerbaren energien
und auch effizienzsteigerungen beim
energieverbrauch wir fordern die
kommission auf ihre stärke in der
förderung der grundlagenforschung in
diesem bereich besonders auszuspielen
wir fordern sie auch auf wir fordern sie
auch auf den co2 emissionshandel als das
zentrale element im kampf gegen den
klimawandel zu stärken in einem
funktionierenden
energiebinnenmarkt zudem ich anmerken
möchte dass er im sinne der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer wirtschaft
dann auch wirklich nicht durch nationale
maßnahmen da und dort noch garniert oder
ausgebremst werden sollte
vielmehr ist es wichtig dass die
kommission gerade auch die chancen
ergreift als großer globaler player für
die europäische union unsere
zusammenarbeit mit partnern in
nordafrika und beispielsweise in den
golf staaten auszubauen wie wichtig es
ist unsere lieferanten struktur im
bereich energie zu diversifizieren das
erleben wir ja gerade in diesen tagen
und insofern hoffe ich auch dass vom
sechsten eu afrika gipfel in diesen
tagen starke impulse für mehr wohlstand
und mehr schutz vor dem klimawandel für
alle beteiligten ausgehen denn meine
damen und herren darauf kommt es doch
letztendlich an dass wir nicht aus angst
vor dem klimawandel uns zu unsinnigen
maßnahmen treiben lassen sondern dass
wir mehr freiheit mehr fortschritt mehr
wohlstand schaffen für deutschland für
europa und für seine partner in der
ganzen welt vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grüne chantal kopf die
ich ebenfalls zu ihrer ersten rede hier
im deutschen bundestag herzlich begrüßen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen europa
ist stark die eu zählt zu den
gefragtesten und einflussreichsten
akteuren in der welt und wir wollen
europa gemeinsam noch stärker machen wie
ja auch die kommission im titel ihres
arbeitsprogramms hervorhebt und
worauf fußt europas stärke liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen unsere stärke
ist unser gemeinsamer binnenmarkt es ist
eine große errungenschaft dass wir
unseren wohlstand gemeinsam
erwirtschaften und auf der grundlage
gemeinsamer regeln campbell mit anderen
betreiben
die pandemie hat uns gelehrt was es
bedeutet wenn die grundfreiheiten dieses
binnenmarkt eingeschränkt sind das gilt
es bei künftigen krisen dieses ausmaß
ist unbedingt zu verhindern und das
gemeinsame eu im zertifikat ist dafür
ein erstes gutes beispiel
damit der kontinent noch enger
zusammenwachsen kann müssen wir lücken
in den europäischen infrastruktur netzen
schließen insbesondere in den bereichen
digitalisierung energie und
schienenverkehr und dabei sollten wir
nicht nur die zentralen transport
korridore im blick haben sondern auch
regionale lückenschlüsse wie zum
beispiel in meiner heimatregion zwischen
freiburg und kollmer um einen echten
mehrwert für die grenzregionen zu
schaffen
wir alle wissen dass die eu mehr ist als
eine wirtschaftsgemeinschaft und ich
möchte dass hier noch mal unterstreichen
ja die eu ist auch eine
wertegemeinschaft und nach innen wie
nach außen eine starke stimme für eine
regelbasierte ordnung für demokratie und
für menschenrechte
und diese europäische wertegemeinschaft
muss ihre stärke und ihre der sie lienz
unter den bedingungen der
systemkonkurrenz und der geopolitik
unter beweis stellen und europas
schärfstes geopolitisches schwerte liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen dass es die
handelspolitik es gehört daher zu den
wichtigsten aufgaben der kommission eine
regelbasierte und zukunftsfähige handels
politik voranzutreiben
die von der bundesregierung unterstützte
neuausrichtung der eu handel strategie
muss ambitioniert umgesetzt werden und
dazu gehört und insbesondere das
nachhaltigkeits kriterien im künftigen
handelsverträgen keine bloßen
lippenbekenntnisse mehr sein dürfen
nachhaltigkeitskriterien müssen endlich
auch konkret verankert und durchsetzbar
sein das ist das entscheidende
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
europa gemeinsam stärker machen ich
freue mich darauf auch mit ihnen hier im
bundestag in den nächsten jahren genau
daran zu arbeiten vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die
cdu/csu-fraktion catharina dos santos
viernheimer und auch sie begrüße ich
ganz herzlich zu ihrer ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen europa
liegt mir im blut ich bin in lissabon
geboren worden aufgewachsen in meinem
wahlkreis bei aachen im dreiländereck
mit offenen grenzen zu belgien und den
niederlanden im herzen europas ich bin
europäerin und in der europäischen union
liegt für mich die zukunft dafür
brauchen wir ein europa das erstens
funktioniert und dass zweitens
zukunftsorientiert ist mit dieser
ansicht bin ich als junger mensch nicht
allein das auswärtige amt hat zusammen
mit dem deutsch französischen jugendwerk
im rahmen der konferenz zur zukunft
europas junge menschen in deutschland
und in frankreich nach ihren prioritäten
für die zukunft europas gefragt allein
in deutschland haben etwa 45.000 junge
menschen teilnehmen was liegt diesen
jungen bürgerinnen und bürger nun am
herzen am häufigsten wurden dort
tatsächlich nicht der klimawandel oder
themen der migration angesprochen
sondern die stärkung der demokratie
hinsichtlich der arbeit der eu
institution erwarten vor allem junge
bürgerinnen und bürger nachvollziehbare
entscheidungen
transparenz und nachvollziehbarkeit sind
der schlüssel für die legitimation
komplexer politischer entscheidungen
wir brauchen keinen sich selbst
blockieren den apparat sondern eine
handlungsfähige und starke eu europa
gemeinsam stärker machen diesen satz
haben wir heute schon ein paar mal
gehört so heißt es im arbeitsprogramm
der europäischen kommission für 2022 die
stärke der eu zeichnet sich nicht nur
durch die erschließung weiterer politik
felder aus bevor wir uns neuerungen zu
wenden sollten wir erst dafür sorgen
dass die bereiche die schon jetzt in der
kompetenz der eu legen auch
funktionieren denn nur das schafft
langfristig vertrauen und
glaubwürdigkeit und ich bin davon
überzeugt europa ist der kontinent der
zukunft unserer zukunft
die kommission selbst formuliert in
ihrem arbeitsprogramm als eins von sechs
übergreifenden politischen zielen in
europa für das digitale zeitalter und
verfolgt einen ambitionierten zeitplan
der weg der digitalen dekade soll
weiterverfolgt werden bis 2030 soll der
digitale wandel vollzogen sein damit
zieht sich digitalisierung wie ein roter
faden durch alle bereiche der
gesetzgebung um nur ein paar beispiele
zu nennen der sogenannte jobs act der
die innovationsfähigkeit und
versorgungssicherheit mit computerchips
gewährleisten soll das gesetz über
digitale dienste zu haftungs und
sicherheitsvorschriften für digitale
plattformen dienste und produkte sowie
das gesetz über digitale märkte zum
umgang und fairen umgang auf plattform
und nicht zuletzt auch die schaffung
einer europäischen digitalen identität
für alle europäerinnen und europäern ich
könnte noch eine vielzahl der
initiativen und gesetze vortragen aber
eins ist klar die eu-kommission hat
erkannt dass die zukunft als projekt des
friedens und des wohlstands auch in der
gestaltung der digitalisierung gibt und
natürlich sind diese
gesetzgebungsprozesse und technischen
abläufe kompliziert aber ihre folgen
werden ein marktvorteil sein gegenüber
anderen regionen dieser welt die
botschaft lautet in europa ist die
freiheit die innovationskraft von
unternehmen und die sicherheit der daten
der nutzerinnen und nutzer gesichert
ein blick in die welt zeigt dass das
nicht selbstverständlich
schutz der daten und chancen der
digitalisierung sind zwei seiten
derselben medaille
unsere verankerten rechte freiheiten und
europäischen werten sollten online wie
offline geachtet werden gerade junge
menschen müssen sich dabei auf uns
verlassen können herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
susanne mittag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen kolleginnen und kollegen
zwölf zeilen im programm aber 40 prozent
des gesamthaushaltes betrifft 450
millionen einwohner so ungefähr
überwiegend im ländlichen raum leben
alle essen und trinken das ist der
bereich ernährung und landwirtschaft
oftmals thematisch völlig isolierte
debattiert allenfalls mit umweltthemen
in verbindung gebracht aber damit auch
völlig unterschätzt besonders auf eu
ebene der im programm aufgeführte green
deal wird zu einem großen also
flächenmäßigen großen anteil von der
landwirtschaft durchgeführt besonders
möchte ich das programm vom hof auf den
tisch erwähnen und nicht nur durch die
französische ratspräsidentschaft
propagierte carbon farming programm und
den damit verbundenen humusaufbau
moorschutz pestizid reduzierung akkus
systeme wald aufbau sowie weitere
nachhaltigkeitsprogramme besonders im
rahmen der gad warten auf die umsetzung
durch uns alle auch die digitalisierung
europäisch kompatibel sehr wohl bis zur
letzten milchkanne ist erforderlich kaum
ein wirtschaftsbereich ist soweit
digitalisiert wie die landwirtschaft sei
es für vermarktungsbereich zukünftiges
label ding für smart farming die daten
müssen nur noch gezielt und zeitnah
ankommen aber da wären wir wieder beim
thema netzausbau da ist auch noch luft
nach oben
aber auch für die ab 2026 erforderlichen
berechnung und überwachung der
nachhaltigkeitsindikatoren wie die co2
speicherung berechnet und angerechnet
wird europaweit einfach zu bedienen und
betrug sicher ist die flächendeckende
digitalisierung ein muss
landwirtschaft und ernährung kann man
also nicht isoliert sehen und neben den
vorgenannten themen wirken sich die
programme maßnahmen und beschlüsse auch
im energetischen bereich aus denn wo
wird ein großteil der energie eigentlich
erzeugt in der landwirtschaft und im
ländlichen raum der landwirtschaftliche
betriebe wirtschaftsbetriebe sind gibt
es auch hier ergänzen der aspekte sei es
in der zulieferung der landwirtschaft
handel arbeitsmärkte und verkehrliche
aspekte wie zum beispiel logistik und
die antriebssysteme in der
landwirtschaft aber auch wechselseitig
geopolitische auswirkungen sind zu
berücksichtigen
besonders im rahmen der
entwicklungspolitischen zusammenarbeit
weltweit befindet sich die
landwirtschaft auch klima bedingt in
einer transformation denn die
außereuropäische lage der ernährung und
landwirtschaft hat auch innereuropäische
auswirkung sei es beim import beim
export und seien wir mal ganz konkret
die afrikanische schweinepest genannt
und nicht zu vergessen und aus aktuellem
anlass leider die überarbeitung der
europäischen notfall versorgung von
lebensmitteln hat gezeigt die einen oder
anderen haben doch die fernsehbilder der
grenze schlangen in erinnerung wo man
sich sorgen macht ob man versorgt wird
und dazu kommt eine veränderte vernetzte
katastrophenvorsorge das ist ein volles
programm für uns alle und wir machen was
draus herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
nächster
geordnete matthias helferich er spricht
von der tribüne
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren im
arbeitsprogramm
2022 der europäischen kommission findet
sich auch der unterpunkt 2.5 förderung
unserer europäischen lebensweise doch
was dann folgt davon er als angriff auf
die europäische lebensweise betrachtet
werden die kommission verweist in ihrem
arbeitsprogramm auf das vor einem jahr
beschlossene
migrations und asylpolitik
für migration und asyl will die
kommission den grundstein für ein
migrations management in ganz europa
legen die mitgliedstaaten sollen nun
auch im bereich der migrations und
asylpolitik
entscheidungskompetenzen zugunsten der
brüsseler bürokratie abgeben die
kommission wünscht sich ein
verteilungsschlüssel für den ewf bulls
den überschuss an jungen männern aus dem
nahen osten und dem afrikanischen
kontinent und dies freilich gegen den
willen der europäischen völker das
meinungsforschungsinstitut insa befragte
im auftrag unserer eu-delegation bürger
in acht mitgliedstaaten lägen diese
lehnen zu 80 prozent den weiteren zuzug
von migranten abfordern den besseren
schutz der eu außengrenzen 40 prozent
sehen ihre persönliche sicherheit durch
migration gefährdet und nochmals 40
prozent fühlen sich in ihrer nationalen
identität bedroht wenn die kommission
wirklich deutsche europäische lebensart
fördern will dann sollte sie auch den
artikulieren willen der europäischen
völker respektieren das eigene bild zu
bewahren und nicht opfer einer großen
transformation werden zu wollen wie es
auch im koalitionsvertrag der ampel
angedroht wird deutschland übt durch die
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
eine negative dominanz aus deutschland
projiziert seine fehlende vorstellung
von souveränität und selbstbehauptung
auf die eu und gefährdet damit die
stabilität europas es ist die
dogmatische fixierung auf die migration
als menschenrecht die de unfähig macht
ihre außengrenzen robus zu verteidigen
und damit die europäische lebensart zu
erhalten die europäer möchten nicht in
abendländischen parallelgesellschaften
leben um ihre migrations sucht gerecht
zu werden ihre koalition ihre koalition
der willigen ist bereits gescheitert und
das europäische migrations management
wird es auch da bin ich sicher vielen
dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
tobias winkler
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
europäische union ist bedroht sieht
bedroht von innen und von außen und das
arbeitsprogramm der kommission für das
jahr 2022 gibt darauf viele antworten
wenn wir auf die bedrohung nach innen
schauen dann denken wir oft an die
rechtsstaatlichkeit man die verletzung
der selben ein in dem ein oder anderen
mitgliedstaat und ich begrüße
außerordentlich das urteil des
europäischen gerichtshofs dass wir einen
sanktionsmechanismus haben um diesen
entwicklungen einhalt zu gebieten die
europäische union ist aber von innen
auch bedroht wenn sie überladen wenn es
überfrachtet wird wenn sie sich wenn sie
von ihren kompetenzen die von uns
demokratisch zugeteilt wurden abrückt
wenn wir über ein finanzmarkt instrument
das viele im letzten jahr noch gar nicht
auf dem schirm hatten versuchen die
sozialpolitik die nachhaltigkeit in
dieser europäischen union zu prägen dann
ist das nicht der weg wie wir das
vertrauen der bürgerinnen und bürger
stärken oder zurückgewinnen wir müssen
uns bei den
institutionen auf unsere kernbereiche
fokussieren wir müssen in der
europäischen union das gut machen für
was sie wir die europäische union
brauchen die institutionen müssen ihren
aufgaben gerecht werden und nicht
versuchen durch die hintertür ihre
kompetenzen auszuweiten
die europäische union ist aber auch
bedroht von außen
wir sind eine werte union wir sind die
antwort auf krieg auf diesem kontinent
die längste friedensperiode
die wir in europa erleben dürfen haben
wir der europäischen union zu verdanken
wir sehen dass auch dieser frieden den
wir lange ist es für sicher geglaubt
haben dass der im osten bedroht ist und
deswegen ist es umso wichtiger wenn wir
in einem wettbewerb der systeme stehen
mit den autoritären staaten die
vermeintlich die oberhand zu gewinnen
droht und auch in der pandemie innovativ
erzählen dass sie besser auf solche
herausforderungen antworten können dann
schaue ich mit blick auf die welt auf
die von ihnen erwähnten 4,6 milliarden
impfdosen die nicht wie sie vielleicht
denken 10 pro einwohner sie müssen über
die grenzen europas hinaus denken wir
haben diesen impfstoff auch produzieren
auch bestellt und auch bezahlt für
andere menschen in der welt kein
kontinent keine region auf der welt hat
so viel impfstoff auch für menschen
ausserhalb der eigenen der eigenen
region produziert wie wir darauf können
wir stolz sein meine damen herr winkler
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage von
herrn weil oder anderen
zwischenbemerkungen aus der fdp-fraktion
nein
wenn wir über die bedrohung von außen
sprechen und über unsere stärken und
über unsere stärke als europäische union
dann ist die in erster linie
durchsetzbar und das haben sie richtig
erkannt durch wirtschaftliche maßnahme
ich vermisse in der handelspolitik die
wiederaufnahme von von wirtschafts- und
von von handelsabkommen wie wir sie
dringend brauchen in dieser welt um
unsere position zu stärken statt dessen
höre ich dass sie diese handelsabkommen
überladen wollen mit irgendwelchen
wünschen die sie noch drauf packen so
dass wir nie eine einigung erzielen
wollen wenn wir nicht weil wenn es uns
nicht gelingt mit staaten wie den
vereinigten staaten von amerika ein
handelsabkommen auf augenhöhe
abzuschließen wenn es uns nicht gelingt
mit kanada-sieger richtig in kraft zu
setzen wie wollen sie denn dann in der
welt bestehen und wie wollen sie denn
andere handelsabkommen wirksam durch
sitzen wir müssen uns auf das
konzentrieren was möglich ist und dann
ist es auch möglich mit einem starken
europa mit einem werte geleiteten europa
ein europa der fried des friedens der
freiheit der rechtsstaatlichkeit diese
welt zu verändern und gemeinsam können
wir europa stärker machen vielen dank
[Applaus]
bevor ich dem nächsten redner das wort
erteile hat das wort zu einer
kurzintervention herr doktor weil
dankeschön frau präsidentin
herr kollege finden sie wirklich dass
diese geschichte wie offenbar auch viele
andere im umso ware wird je öfter man
sie erzählt und zwar egal wie oft sie
widerlegt sind durch
nicht nur menschenverstand sondern
forschung durch aktuelle politische
diplomatische et cetera praxis das heißt
die eu die er offenbar ein schlechtes
wirtschaftsprojekt ist ist dafür ein
umso besseres friedensprojekt diese
legende hält sich über die jahrzehnte
2005 als es um die verfassung gegen die
sogenannte eu verfassung die dann
abgelehnt wurde und im lissabonner
vertrag endete war das auch der große
gimmick es ist der frieden bedroht in
europa wenn die eu nicht in dieser
bisherigen form und verschlingt stets
verschlimmbessert in form fortbesteht
der frieden in europa tor wohl zu tun
mit der nato und mit dem anfang der 60er
jahre installierten roten telefon
zwischen washington und moskau
es hat nichts damit zu tun was in paris
oder früher bonn berlin selbst in london
entschieden wurde nicht nur die
deutschen sondern die gesamten europäer
sind und zwar nicht nur militärisch ein
schatten ihrer selbst nach 45 und ohne
die vernünftige immer wieder aus
washington und aus moskau führte hätte
es weder eine deutsche wiedervereinigung
gegeben noch den frieden in europa und
abschließend der frieden in europa
schönen gut nach 45 wurden mehr kriege
geführt als von 1945 und mit 18
millionen toten haben die kriege in der
dritten welt wo sehr wohl unsere freunde
in frankreich unsere englischen freunde
und so weiter die ganzen kolonialmächte
beteiligt waren 18 millionen tote
gefordert so viel wie der erste
weltkrieg also es ist kein
friedensprojekt es kein europäisches
verdienst dass hier ein paar jahrzehnte
ruhe war im karton danke schön herr
winkler möchten sie darauf antworten sie
dann haben sie das wort
ja herr kollege weil es ganze jetzt
nicht gleichzeitig anschauen aber ich
kann ihnen doch antworten dass europa
wenn sie die geschichte europas
anschauen dann können sie allein in den
letzten 500 jahren sehen dass es keine
längere friedensperiode gab als die seit
dem ende des ersten weltkriegs dass wir
in dieser freiheit und diesen die
kriegen in einem freiheitlichen
parlament indem sie solche reden halten
dürfen das haben wir einem europa zu
verdanken dass die grenzen dass die
grenzen überwunden hat dass die
erzfeindschaft zwischen
frankreich und deutschland im
mittelpunkt überwunden hat das ist eine
historische leistung der europäischen
union und 2012 der friedensnobelpreis
war eine berechtigte würdigung dieser
großartigen leistung und wenn sie hier
klein reden wollen was die europäische
union für den frieden auf diesem
kontinent geleistet hat dann haben sie
die geschichte der europäischen union
dann haben sie diese geschichte dieses
kontinents nicht verstanden
ja vielen dank guten morgen meine damen
und herren ich begrüße sie hier live aus
dem plenum den 9 uhr über das
arbeitsprogramm der eu kommission mit
dem tipp titel europa gemeinsam stärken
die ziele grob im überblick europa soll
bis 2050 zum ersten klimaneutralen
kontinent der welt werden neben dem
pionier paket fit for 50 5 soll ein
rechtsrahmen für die zertifizierung der
co2 entfernung vorgeschlagen werden und
so manch anderer punkt und der nächste
redner hier ist timon gremmels für die
spd fraktion
hat auch dieser koalition war das als
erste amtshandlung im neuen jahr
zwischen silvester und neujahr die eu
kommission dann die taxonomie für
atomkraft auf den weg gebracht hat nach
motto atomkraft sei nachhaltig da bin
ich froh dass wir als koalition genau
das nicht sagen wir sind nicht der
auffassung dass atomkraft teil der
lösung ist meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren aber kaum ist friedrich merz
im amt hat er wohl und den schubladen
geguckt die ja da vor 20 jahren
zurückgelassen hat aber noch irgendwas
findet und da ist ihm scheinbar ein
papier in die hände gekommen dass die
union jetzt auch wieder für atomkraft
sei es schon spannend 20 jahre zeit
vergessenheit die sie da erlebt haben
und jetzt auf einmal sind sie die
verfechter der renaissance der atomkraft
das sagt doch viel über die cdu/csu raus
meine sehr verehrten damen und
wir sind froh dass er ende dieses jahres
die letzten drei atomkraftwerke vom netz
gehen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren wir können fifty five nur
erringen und hinbekommen wenn wir
deutlich die erneuerbaren energien
ausbauen und ich fand es etwas schade
dass da im arbeitsprogramm der
kommission zum beispiel für den bereich
solar zwei lapidare sätze drinstehen
vernommen dass im april dieses jahres
seine strategie kommen soll das ziel ist
ausgegeben bis 2030 auf europäischer
ebene 4 120 gigawatt hinzu zu bauen da
wenn wir unseren koalitionsvertrag zu
grunde legen dass wir davon schon 200
gigawatt leisten dann kann die union
dann kann die europäische union tag gern
noch eine schippe drauf geben meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir geben da
gerne auch unterstützung ja wir müssen
in der tat auch gucken dass parallel zu
dem was die kommission macht auch im
europäischen parlament verhandelt wird
da ist derzeit in die erneuerbare
energien richtlinie auf dem tisch und da
wollen wir auch nochmal nachschärfen
auch hier muss klar sein auch in zukunft
brauchen wir für windparks mit bis zu 18
megawatt klar die die minimis regelung
also die frage auch der nicht
ausschreibung von solchen flächen das
stärkt kommunale stadtwerke gestärkt
bürger energiegenossenschaften auch für
photovoltaik auf dachflächen kann ich
mir gut vorstellen von privathäusern
dass das zukünftig ohne ausschreibung
geht meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren wir bringen damit die
erneuerbaren energien voran ja wir
diskutieren derzeit auch sehr viel über
das den europäischen emissionshandel und
die ausweitung auf die bereiche
straßenverkehr und gebäude das hat
allerdings natürlich wir haben ja gleich
die nächsten tagesordnungspunkt dazu
immense auswirkungen auch auf die
energiepreis das muss abgefedert werden
das ist aus meiner sicht ganz offiziell
wichtig und deswegen ist es gut dass
auch dort ein klima sozialfond aufgelegt
werden soll der muss aber auch
treffsicher sein sonst verlieren wir die
unterstützung der mehrheit der menschen
ist darf nicht sein dass die die zeche
zahlen sondern wir müssen die
energiewende wir müssen auch den
europäischen emissionshandel so
ausgestalten dass menschen entlastet
werden meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren
die frau staatsministerin hat eben ich
fand das zitat zuletzt gesagt unser
europäisches haus braucht eine
klimaneutrale renovierung auf begehung
es eben auf parlamentsebene macht das
die regierung macht das die koalitions
tragenden fraktionen aber die
renovierung ist ja auch was ganz
praktisches die renovierung der gebäude
machen die handwerkerinnen und
handwerker und da haben wir einen
massiven fachkräftemangel und leider
leider steht bei einem konzept im
arbeitsprogramm der eu-kommission viel
zu wenig drin wie wir diesen massiven
fachkräftemangel
ja ja abbauen können wenn wir die
energiewende wenn wir den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien über die sanierung
und renovierung hinbekommen wollen
brauchen wir fachkräfte und da müssen
wir noch ein bisschen investieren damit
uns da das gelingt meine damen und
herren frau präsidentin ich komme zum
schluss ich sehe oder wir als
regierungskoalition und insbesondere spd
sieht im klimaschutz in der energiewende
eine riesenchance für die europäische
gesellschaft für die europäische
wirtschaft und auch für die menschen
nachhaltige energieerzeugung kann zum
standortfaktor werden damit europa der
erste klimaneutrale kontinent wird und
dafür wird diese koalition ihren beitrag
leisten vielen dank glück auf
timon gremmels von der spd war der
letzte redner hierzu der vereinbarten
debatte arbeitsprogramm der europäischen
kommission und er hat es angesprochen
der nächste tagesordnungspunkt der
betrifft uns alle
nämlich der tagesordnungspunkt
energiepreise die oppositionsfraktionen
haben jeweils eigene anträge vorgelegt
explosion bei den energiepreisen
bekämpfen zeitnah wirksam und gericht
entlasten das fordert die cdu csu die
linke verbraucher sind und verbraucher
vor energiepreissteigerungen schützen
und die ard hat ein antrag der heißt
kraftstoffpreise sinken wirtschaft
unterstützen wirtschaftskrise verhindern
und der erste redner wird ihnen sehr
bekannt vorkommen es ist nämlich jens
spahn es geht hier nicht mehr um
gesundheit das ist so üblich in ein
minister aus dem amt ausgeschieden ist
wechselt er quasi das ressort jens spahn
ist jetzt der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion für den
bereich wirtschaft und energie und die
ganze debatte hier dauert 67 minuten und
dürfte glaube ich jeden verbraucher
interessieren die opposition kritisiert
eben dass die koalition zu wenig tue um
die verbraucher zu entlasten
dabei hat die koalition ja beim
heizkostenzuschuss schon eine entlastung
vorgenommen und jetzt also jens spahn
quasi in ganz neuer funktionen
ich möchte zu beginn der debatte drei
punkte ansprechen erstens ganz
grundsätzlich es gibt drei themen die
die bürgerinnen und bürger dieser tage
ganz besonders beschäftigt russland
ukraine kroner explodierender
energiepreise zu allen drei themen
finden in dieser woche hier im deutschen
bundestag debatten statt das ist gut
aber
sie werden hier nur diskutiert weil wir
die union die opposition sich hier zum
thema machen
und das ist noch bemerkenswerter
und das ist noch bemerkenswerter zu all
diesen drei themen ukraine russland
corona und auch zu den explodierenden
energiepreisen hat die regierung haben
die minister der regierung anscheinend
hier nichts zu sagen sie haben in der
koalition viel über parlamentarismus in
den koalitionsvertrag geschrieben haben
viel kluges dazugehört parlamentarismus
stärkt man vor allem dadurch dass man
ihnen lebt in denen wir die banken hier
im deutschen bundestag stattfindet die
regierung sich hier im deutschen
bundestag erklärt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
zweitens zur explosion der energiepreise
sei eines vorneweg gesagt dass die
preise steigen liegt offenkundig nicht
in der verantwortung der regierung das
wäre jede regierung so gegangen das hat
was mit entscheidungen oder nicht
entscheidungen der vergangenheit zu tun
vor allem aber mit gedrosselten
gaslieferungen aus russland die nur ihre
verträge aber eben auch nicht mehr
erfüllen nein dass die dass die preise
steigen liegt nicht in ihrer
verantwortung aber dass es keine
schnelle keine schnell wirksame reaktion
gibt das liegt in ihrer verantwortung
ein heizkostenzuschuss ist gut ein
heizkostenzuschuss ist gut dabei
erreicht nicht er ist führt zu wenige zu
wenig energiepreise sind mittlerweile
eine echte soziale frage
krankenpfleger polizistin handwerker all
diejenigen die unser land am laufen
halten die machen mittlerweile mit einem
ziemlich klamm gefühl die heizungswärme
events kalte tage gibt wir müssen an der
zapfsäule sehr genau überlegen wie viele
da benzin ist denn heute sein müssen
handwerker bis hin zum großkonzern die
unternehmen überlegen sich gerade sehr
genau ob sie investitionen hier in
deutschland machen ob sie aufschieben
fallenlassen ins ausland verlegen all
diese menschen können nicht auf wärmeres
wetter warten die brauchen entlastung
bei den preisen und zwar jetzt und
sofort liebe kolleginnen und kollegen du
darfst du schlagen wir einiges vor die
eeg-umlage abzuschaffen die stromsteuer
und die mehrwertsteuer auf die energie
deutlich zu senken die pendlerpauschale
auf 38 cent zu erhöhen was sind nur drei
der wichtigsten maßnahmen und die sind
übrigens auch fair und finanzierbar weil
nicht zuletzt der staat mit verdient an
den höheren energiepreisen bei der
mehrwertsteuer bei hohen co2 preisen das
ist nur fair und gerecht wenn in dieser
schwierigen lage auch in dieser sozialen
frage die bürgerinnen und bürger dann
auch wieder entlastet werden und das ist
das was wir einfordern
sie reden viel vom sofortprogramm
klimaschutz ist ja auch alles okay aber
was ist braucht noch dringlicher braucht
ist ein preise runter sofortprogramm ein
entlastungsprogramm und zwar sofort herr
minister das ist jedenfalls das was wir
erwarten das ist vor allem das was die
bürgerinnen und bürger erwarten uns auch
erwarten dürfen
und drittens in aller kürze unsere
starke abhängigkeit vom russischen gas
erweist sich auch als ziemliche achilles
ferse das spüren wir dieser tage
schmerzhaft wer aber aus kernenergie
und kohle aus steigt braucht auch wenn
er in erneuerbare energien stärker
einsteigt auf absehbare zeit gas und er
braucht vor allem versorgungssicherheit
und sie können jetzt zehnter debatte
darüber führen was alles hätte
entschieden werden müssen sie regieren
gerade sie müssen mit den dingen wie sie
sind umgehen und deswegen deswegen
müssen wir offenkundig
offenkundig auch ein sofortprogramm für
gas haben für mehr gaskraftwerke
verlässliche gaslieferungen mehr
strategische gasreserven für lng
terminal für flüssiggas aus dem ausland
das haben sie ja herr minister
richtigerweise gesagt ich sehe nur bei
den begriff lng terminals ihre eigene
fraktion in teilen doch schon zucken wir
sehen doch wie an den standorten den
möglichen jetzt schon die ersten grünen
bürgerinitiativen sich wieder gründen
und in bewegung setzen ich weiß nicht ob
sie ihre fraktionen und ihre partei beim
thema lng terminal an ihrer seite haben
uns als union haben sie dabei an ihrer
seite wir brauchen lng terminals und
flüssiggas um nicht so stark abhängig zu
sein vom
russland
kurzum liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir erwarten dass die regierung zu den
fragen unserer zeit hier im deutschen
bundestag stellung bezieht auch und
gerade zu den explodierenden
energiepreisen und
wir fordern taten wie wir sie in unserem
antrag beschreiben ankündigen und
ankündigungen und warme worte alleine
lindern die finanzielle not der
bürgerinnen und bürger der unternehmen
in deutschland nicht die brauchen ein
preis runter programm sofort
[Applaus]
also die cdu csu opposition jetzt in der
angenehmen situation zu fordern das
einfach mal entlastungen herkommen
sollen spannender natürlich recht viele
belastungen entstehen durch den staat
aber dieses geld ist ja eigentlich
verplant das wird sicherlich michael
show die der finanzpolitische sprecher
der spd jetzt das wort hat auch erwähnen
nicht
zu ende wir leben geopolitische
konflikte die eskalieren drohen wir
erfahren auch und daraus resultierend
lieferengpässe und ein preisschock bei
fossilen energieträgern die
bundesregierung und die sie tragenden
fraktionen
arbeiten mit hochdruck und beständig
daran lösungen für all diese themen zu
formulieren wir haben einiges auf den
weg gebracht wir werden einige auf den
weg bringt die wirkungsvoll die schnell
umsetzbar und finanzierbar sind
zum thema energie preissteigerung ist
drei anträge zweier bad boy von afg und
linke
bemerkenswert ist aber auch ich sagte
unruhigen es ist zu sehen wie cdu und
csu in atemberaubender geschwindigkeit
der langjährigen regierungspartei zu
einer unseriösen
oppositionspartei sich entwickelt diese
antrag zeigt es deutlich an drei punkten
zum einen was sie vorlägen ist ein
bauchladen alles was sie so zu gerufen
wo im letzten wochen haben sie da
reingepackt 22 einzelmaßnahmen die sich
doppeln die sich ausschließen die sogar
kontraproduktiv sind ich sagte sie
wollen einerseits bei der stromsteuer
die abzusenken und wollen auch noch der
spitzenausgleich gleichzeitig angehen
das ist obsolet wenn sie das eine tun es
sind vollkommen ein sammelsurium nicht
aufeinander abgestimmter
einzelforderungen statt gezielter
maßnahmen die von ihnen als ehemaliger
erwartet hätte deshalb auch lehnen wir
diesen antrag ab ich darf auch zitieren
aus ihren antrag sie fordern nämlich auf
die bundesregierung im rahmen der
verfügbaren haushaltsmittel diese
forderungen umzusetzen
das ist eine interessante forderungen
sie heißt entweder sie wollen mit blick
auf die haushaltslage die forderung gar
nicht umsetzen oder sie müssen farbe
bekennen wie wollen sie denn das alles
finanzieren wollen sie höhere steuern
wollen sie neue kredite
denn anders sind ihre 22 punkte gar
nicht zu finanzieren die zeitung die
welt hat das mal ausgerechnet ich
übrigens auch
40 milliarden euro würden alle maßnahmen
kosten die sie hier aufgeschrieben ohne
ein wort der gegenfinanzierung dass es
einen oppositions wolkenkuckucksheim
antrag aber keine seriöse politik die
sie hier vortragen herr spahn
und in der so genannten toolbox ersparen
die sie
aufnehmen oder wie sie beziehen die
toolbox eu kommission davor die
kommission insbesondere
soziale
unterstützungsmaßnahmen möglichst als
pauschale zeitlich befristete
zielgerichtete entlastungen für
bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen aber nicht
maßgaben machst oder mit der gießkanne
die zum teil speziell spitzenverdiener
entlasten würden wir haben und wir
werden
gezielte maßnahmen für die auf den weg
bringen die besonders unter den
energiepreisen den gaspreisen zu leiden
haben das sind kleinere und mittlere
einkommen gesagt wir tun ich sondern wir
haben nichts vor natürlich sie müssen
nun mal genauer zuhören vielleicht
einmal die zeitung lesen
heizkostenzuschuss wohl geld wohngeld
dynamisierung übrigens da heute erste
lesung wohngeld dynamisierung
vorgezogene abschaffung eeg-umlage
weiteren maßnahmen wie der mindestlohn
wird helfer sofort zuschlag für kinder
endlich mal eine gerechte aufteilung des
co2 preisen zwischen mieter und
vermieter was mit ihnen nicht zu machen
macht oder auch die mindest
ausbildungsvergütung bringen wir auf den
weg und zuletzt
muss man ja deutlich sagen herr sparen
das ist eine fossile inflation es sind
die fossilen energieträger für die
preise treiben deshalb werden wir auch
mittel und langfristig dafür sorgen dass
die preise senken weil die günstigsten
preise erhalten wir mit den erneuerbaren
energien oder saßen die doch ist ein
treppenwitz der geschichte dass sie uns
jetzt auffordern wollen die erneuerbaren
energien schneller ausbauen auszubauen
sie schlafen doch am kabinettstisch
das sagt ein herr altmaier auch mit
dabei ich kann mich erinnern dass es
derjenige war der gebremst hat die solar
deckel drauf belasten hat bei der
windenergie begrenzt hat das sind doch
diejenigen und glaube auch dass in ihrer
dass in der csu
dass es da den bayerischen windkraft
hinter markus söder gibt der in bayern
verhindert dass erneuerbare energien
ausbauen da kehren sie vor ihrer haustür
wir werden als bundesregierung die
notwendigen maßnahmen die schnell
umsetzbar sind auf den weg bringen und
wir werden die mittel und langfristigen
lösungen nämlich den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien voranbringen das
tun wir gemeinsam geschlossen in dieser
neuen position und darauf freue ich mich
mal sr geehrten damen und herren ja und
an diesem versprechen werden die wähler
die spd und herren schrodi messen zum
beispiel die senkung der eeg umlage die
die fdp h für mitte des jahres
durchsetzen will widerstand dagegen gibt
es allerdings auch schon nämlich bei den
grünen die umlage um einen cent
abzusenken koste rund fünf milliarden
euro sagte die klima- und
energiepolitische sprecherin der grünen
bundestagsfraktion
ingrid nestle und der nächste redner ist
jetzt zunächst bernd schattner von der
afd
das leben wird für die menschen in
deutschland immer teurer seit monaten
sehen wir immer stärker steigende preise
bei lebensmitteln
wohnkosten und energiekosten die
aktuelle inflationsrate liegt
mittlerweile bei rund fünf prozent
im dezember hatten wir die höchste
inflation seit über 30 jahren
zusätzlich werden die sparer durch die
aktuelle niedrigzinspolitik durch die
hintertüre enteignet es wird höchste
zeit dass die unsere bürger hier spürbar
entlasten und insbesondere die
energiepreise steigenden
schwindelerregende höhen das tägliche
leben jetzt für viele menschen in
unserem land bald unbezahlbar sein egal
ob wir uns die spritpreise anschauen
oder die nächste heizkostenabrechnung
zur zeit können die preise nur eine
richtung stark nach oben und sicherlich
erinnern sich noch jeder von ihnen an
die aussage unseres jetzigen kanzlers
dass er nicht selbst tanken und daher
die preise nicht kennt mit anderen
worten der bundeskanzler hat keine
ahnung wie teuer das leben in
deutschland mittlerweile geworden ist
aber fragen sie doch mal ihre wähler zu
hause im wahlkreis die können es ihnen
ganz genau sagen die märkte es nämlich
tägliche die am geldbeutel die meisten
abgeordneten hier im haus dürften die
preise vermutlich nicht kennen daher
macht sie ihre informationen heute
morgen kostete der liter super in binz
in berlin mittlerweile ein euro 85 aber
schauen wir in dem zusammenhang noch
einmal in unsere nachbarländer wie diese
mit dem aktuellen problem umgehen polen
hat aktuell die mehrwertsteuer auf
kraftstoffe von 23 8 prozent gesenkt und
damit ist der liter sprit in polen
mittlerweile um rund 60 cent billiger
als in deutschland
und während an der grenze zu polen die
tankstellen auf deutscher seite
verweisen und die pächter kurz vor dem
ruin stehen und der tanktourismus
nachholen und nicht nur bei steuern und
abgaben sind die europaweit
spitzenreiter auch unsere
kraftstoffpreise gehören mittlerweile zu
den höchsten in der jungen in meiner
anfrage an das bundesfinanzministerium
auf eine senkung der mehrwertsteuer bzw
energie steuern auf kraftstoffe in
deutschland möglich wäre bekam ich
folgende antwort die umsatz und die
energie steuer werden erhoben um die
finanzierung der staatlichen aufgaben zu
sichern eine senkung dieser steuern
würde ihre lenkungswirkung schmälern und
fortschritte bei der bekämpfung des
klimawandels verlangsamen offensichtlich
ist doch hier mittlerweile die einst
liberale fdp vor dem zeitgeistes grün
klima waren es komplett eingebrochen
unser politischer grundsatz ist die
region des deutschen steuerzahlers und
eben nicht die des weltklimas aktuell
sind mittlerweile 60 prozent des
spritpreises auf steuern und abgaben an
den fiskus zurückzuführen und deswegen
sind unsere forderungen nach einer
befristeten absenkung der mehrwertsteuer
sowie die abschaffung der co2 steuer
ökonom misch und gesellschaftlich das
gebot der stunde ich kann natürlich
nachvollziehen dass ihre links grün
gelbe koalition überhaupt kein interesse
an einer lösung der hier debattierten
probleme hat schließlich führen die
horrenden preise zu sprudelten
steuereinnahmen an der zapfsäule die
hier vorgestellten vorschläge der union
zielen eigentlich in die richtige
richtung leider geben sie aber auch den
airbag des klima aktivismus in ihren
forderungen mit und deshalb werden wir
diesen antrag uns enthalten müssten
dahingegen ist unser vorgestellte antrag
zur senkung der mehrwertsteuer ein
antrag zur entlastung der unternehmen
arbeitnehmer und familien in deutschland
gleichermaßen und beide immer stärker
werdenden staatlichen gängelung der
menschen in unserem land sind wir uns
als alternative für deutschland nicht
nur dem schutz der bürger irgendeinen
grünen klima waren der bundesregierung
verpflichtet sondern ebenso dem schutz
der grundrechte und genau aus diesem
grund werden wir auch am fünften mehr
als einen deutschlandweiten aktionstag
gegen eine staatlich verordnete ihm
pflicht veranstalten und doch mal zurück
zum antrag stimmen sie unserem antrag zu
sie würden damit insbesondere den
ländlichen raum unterstützen die
wirtschaft ankurbeln und das jeden eines
jeden einzelnen in deutschland leichter
machen vielen dank
der bundestag debattiert über massnahmen
gegen zu hohe energiepreise und die
nächste rednerin hatte ich vorhin schon
angesprochen ingrid nestle sprecherin
für klimaschutz und energie sie hat
gesagt in einem interview
dass die eeg-umlage streichung der
völlig falsche weg sei das koste 5
milliarden euro die hälfte würde schon
reichen um den menschen die wirklich
moment probleme hätten mit den hohen
energiepreisen zu helfen im westen
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen herrscher sie
haben es geschafft in einer rede auf die
energiewende zu schimpfen die unsere
unabhängigkeit von den fossilen
reduzieren würde und mit krokodilstränen
das zu beweinen was die abhängigkeit der
vorziehen für folgen hat nämlich die
hohen energiepreise das ist
bemerkenswert aber nicht seriös
und damit und damit zu ihrem antrag
werte kolleginnen und kollegen der cdu
sie sind mutig das muss man ihnen lassen
sie führen unter punkt 2 ganz korrekt
auf was wir brauchen um uns zu lösen aus
dieser abhängigkeit von den fossilen um
zu verhindern die ursachen die gerade
die preissteigerung verursachen zwei
beispiele effizienz steigern nur dass
sie in ihrer regierungszeit diesen punkt
ja nicht nur unzureichend vorangetrieben
haben sondern sogar zum teil aktiv
hinter prima ein beispiel nur nehmen wir
die effizienz bei autos sie haben der eu
aktiv verhindert dass wir anspruchsvolle
effizienzvorgaben haben und beim
effizienzlabel für autos sind die autos
besser die schwerer sind dafür haben sie
sich eingesetzt dass es keinen
fortschritt bei der effizienz
ähnlich ist unabhängigkeit von fossilen
diana wahnsinn trieb ihnen eingebrochen
die sanierung ist nicht vorangekommen
von daher ja es ist mutig dass sie das
benennen und natürlich brauchen wir
kurzfristig maßnahmen um mit den
energiepreisen um auf den hohen
energiepreise zu reduzieren aber das
jetzt aus allen rohren gleichzeitig in
der subventions kanone schießen wollen 9
milliarden umsatzsteuer 7 milliarden
stromsteuer zehn milliarden kalte
progression
simone zielgenauigkeit schießen wollen
das ist natürlich nicht die lösung und
deshalb
deshalb soll man sagen sie haben sich
sehr schnell und sehr umfassend in ihre
rolle als opposition eingefunden aber
aus den genannten gründen könnte den
antrag leider nicht annehmen
und zugleich wir haben schon mehrere
maßnahmen auf den weg gebracht und
arbeiten weiteres hat mein kollege
gerade ausgeführt ich glaube das kann
ich meinen letzten drei sekunden nicht
denn zugleich
würden sie mir einmal ganz kurz noch
fertig zu hören zugleich möchte ich ihr
angebot annehmen ja ich freue mich dass
sie erkannt haben dass wir jetzt
energieeffizienz brauchen das wir
unabhängigkeit von den fossilen brauchen
und lassen sie uns sehr gerne gemeinsam
nach lösungen suchen denn die
unternehmen und die menschen im land
brauchen zweierlei sie brauchen
zielgerichtete unterstützung
zielgerichtete unterstützung da wo es am
meisten schmerzt kurzfristig weil wir in
der patsche sitzen wegen dem was
unterblieben ist und wir brauchen aber
auch langfristige planungssicherheit und
da hilft es bestimmt wenn wir einen
breiten konsens hinbekommen der uns aus
der sorgenden abhängigkeit von den
fossilen energien lösen kann herzlichen
dank
wenn er die zwischenfrage stellen zwei
minuten
nächste rednerin für die fraktion die
linke amira mohammed ali
sie ist die fraktionsvorsitzende und die
linken fordern eine sofortige
einmalzahlung von 200 euro an alle
menschen deren einkommen unter der
armutsschwelle liegt
der frau präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen die gestiegene energiekosten
sind ein riesenproblem im schnitt sind
sie im laufe des letzten jahres bereits
kosten um circa 50 bei sprit um 38
prozent bei strom um 9 prozent
angestiegen das kann so wirklich nicht
weiter
denn was das konkret bedeutet das möchte
ich jetzt mal ein beispiel festmachen
eine frisörin in brandenburg die
verdient 1300 euro netto im monat oder
andere sich nicht vorstellen können dass
es so wenig ist aber das ist bittere
realität für millionen arbeitnehmer auch
in vollzeit auch in ausbildungsberufen
viele verdienen sogar weniger sie wohnt
in einer zweizimmerwohnung und pendelt
jeden morgen 25 kilometer mit dem auto
zur arbeit denn da fährt kein bus auch
das ist realität für millionen menschen
unserem land dieser weg kostet sie heute
etwa 50 euro mehr im monat als vor einem
jahr für die warme wohnung sind es
mindestens 70 euro für strom kommen noch
mal zehn euro mehr dazu macht zusammen
130 euro monatliche mehrbelastung das
sind zehn prozent des monatsmittels und
was das konkret bedeutet heißt dass
viele menschen sich ernsthaft fragen
müssen heizen oder essen und das ist
doch wirklich ein skandal
und was tut jetzt die bundesregierung
gehen wir die maßnahmen durch die wollen
den menschen die wohngeldberechtigt sind
135 euro heizkostenzuschuss seien nicht
pro monat nein nur einmal das reicht
nicht aus und wissen sie was die
friseurin die bekommt davon gar nicht
waldi halten sich fest dafür zu viel
verdient
richtig wäre stattdessen was wir fordern
dass der co2 preis auf in der tiefe
mieterinnen und mieter sofort entfällt
sie wollen auch verdient die eeg-umlage
nächstes jahr streichen gut aber die not
die herrscht doch jetzt das ist viel zu
spät wir fordern daher die
mehrwertsteuer energie zu senken von 19
auf 7 prozent das bringt bares geld für
die bürgerinnen und bürger und zwar
zeigte
christian lindner hat außerdem gesagt
die pendlerpauschale die solle erhöht
werden da verrate ich ihnen jetzt mal
was auch davon hat die friseurin aus
brandenburg gar nichts
heiliges einkommen zahlt sie kaum
steuern sie kann heute nicht mein die
pendlerpauschale voll ausnutzen
stattdessen wäre es richtig was wir
fordern ein mobilitäts geld auszuzahlen
das wird direkt ausgezahlt davon
profitieren alle pendlerinnen und
pendler dass wir die richtige schritt
kolleginnen kollegen
nehmen diesen effektiven sofortmaßnahmen
braucht es natürlich auch langfristige
konzepte zum beispiel die einführung
einer funktionierenden staatlichen
preisaufsicht für energie außerdem muss
der strompreis von spekulationen an der
börse endlich in coppito
und spies dass einige auch hier im hause
die hohen energiekosten befürworten weil
sie meinen dass leute dann weniger auto
fahren weil sie meinen dass das den
klimaschutz voran berichtet aber das ist
ein irrglaube denn die friseurinnen
brandenburg hat wie viele andere keine
alternative zum auto und was die hohen
spritkosten bewirken ja das kann man
aktuell an der deutsch polnischen grenze
bestaunen der tanktourismus punkt und
übrigens nicht nur bei den bürgerinnen
und bürgern führen die hohen
energiekosten zu löcher im portemonnaie
auch die klammen kommunen leiden die
heute kaum noch wissen wie sie
bibliothek oder schwimmbad offen halten
sollen und die preissenkung im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr die für
die verkehrswende wichtig werden die
rücken so in immer weitere ferne ist der
falsche weg und außerdem
und außerdem sehen sie ja dass die
ewiggestrigen von rechts die preis
explosion ausnutzen um den dringend
notwendigen klimaschutz pauschal zu
diskreditieren ein grund mehr den
steigenden verbraucherpreisen sofort ein
heizung bieten kolleginnen kollegen
zusammenfassend für uns als linke ist
klar das leben das muss bezahlbar sein
und zwar für alle
damen und herren wir haben hier mehrfach
schon jetzt den
bundeswirtschaftsminister auf der
regierungsbank gesehen wenn ich so
richtig drüber schauen wird er in dieser
debatte hier jedenfalls nicht das wort
ergreifen
ganz anders ist das mit michael kruse
denen die hier schon erkennen können
erst der energiepolitische sprecher der
fdp fraktion und hat jetzt als nächster
das wort in der debatte über die
energiepreise im deutschen bundestag und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
insbesondere lieber kollege sparen ich
wusste immer dass wir beide in einer
unterschiedlichen
realität leben dass wir uns hier
ausgerechnet von der person die
eineinhalb jahre
alles im bereich der korona politik an
diesem hause hier vorbei gewunken hat
anhören müssen wir müssten jetzt die
relevanten debatten ins parlament das
ein treppenwitz des jahres herr kollege
sparen
und bei ihrem antrag geht es ja gerade
weiter ich habe den mit einer gewissen
verwunderung gelesen denn eigentlich
handelt es sich hierbei um die
mängelliste der unions energiepolitik
meine damen und herren wir kehren jetzt
hinter ihrer arbeit hin und her weil sie
jahrelang hier oben auf diesen welten
überhaupt nichts auf die kette kriegt
haben sie schreiben und da ist ja das
spannende wo sind sie eigentlich ganz
besonders unscharf sie schreiben den
schaden tragen nun die endkunden den
erheblich teurere grundversorgung story
verfallen ja aber die verantwortung
lieber kollege sparen die trägt ihre
bundesregierung die letzte
bundesregierung die sich insbesondere im
bereich bereich der regulierung der
gasmärkte überhaupt nichts auf die kette
gebracht hat wir brauchen in diesem
bereich eine nachtwächterstaat der
nachtwächter der hatte bisher ein
schwarzes parteibuch nur leider hat der
nachtwächter geschlafen und wenn der
nachtwächter im nachtwächterstaat
schläft dann wird es besonders bitter
das liegt in ihrer verantwortung wir
räumen jetzt auf hinter ihrer politik
meine liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der uns
und jetzt jetzt wird es ganz besonders
spannend der erste satz ihres antrags
der eine inhaltlich forderung auf macht
lautet ja gleich wir kassieren den rest
des antrags nämlich ihre haushälter
waren zumindest so wachsam herzlichen
dank an den kolleginnen und kollegen
einen haushaltsvorbehalt hier rein zu
schreiben und ich bin sehr gespannt ob
von ihnen hier gleich noch jemand in die
rede geht und von ihren haushältern und
uns erklärt wo denn das geld liegt was
sie hier alles für ausgaben wollen ich
finde es ganz spannend ich komme gleich
darauf zurück ich finde es ja ganz
spannend wie ihr parlaments verständnis
ist sie haben von uns parlamentsdebatte
eingefordert und die führen wir gerne
wie sie sehen nur eins ist neu für mich
die regierung
verständigt sich darauf die eeg-umlage
abzuschaffen die regierung ist bereit
die eeg umlagen abschaffung sogar
vorzuziehen aufgrund der ernsten lage in
der wir sind und jetzt kommen sie mit
einem oppositionsantrag und fordernd
genau das munter von uns meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren sie von der
union sie müssen in der opposition
wirklich noch sehr viel lernen
sie haben ja eine ganze ganze ein
bisschen überspringe ich jetzt die
kollegen die geschätzten kollegen aus
der ampel sind ja darauf eingegangen
dass sehr viele forderungen sich teils
widersprechen manche halten wir im
grundsatz auch für richtig natürlich
wäre es gute stromsteuern bis hin zu
senken aber sie müssen dann eben auch
einen vorschlag machen wir kommen wir in
die haushaltsberatung und jeder der mit
einem guten vorschlag um die ecke kommt
kann ja dann auch für sich in anspruch
nehmen eine maßnahme auch durchzusetzen
was mich ganz besonders verwundert hat
ist dass sie die tür richtung
atomenergie auf lassen hier am antrag
denn genau diese form von politik ist es
ja die uns ja erst in diesen hohen preis
lage geführt hat ihre energiepolitik und
die abhängigkeit von den fossilen hat
dazu geführt dass wir in dieser
dramatischen lage sind ich kann ihnen
von der union nur sehr raten nur weil
sie herrn märz wieder zum vorsitzenden
gewählt haben müssen sie in der
energiepolitik nicht auch in die 90er
jahre zurück die kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir werden mit dieser ampel koalition
das zeitalter der erneuerbaren
beschreiten wir werden kabel liegt
verhindern und wir werden das erreichen
weil wir die probleme beim
planungsrechtlich sie nicht haben
ausräumen können nun endlich beheben
damit wir voran kommt und damit die
preise in diesem land sinken und zwar
dauerhaft und zwar von dem niveau was
sie uns eingebrockt haben herzlichen
dank
michael krüger mit teilweise sehr
persönlichen
anwürfen die er vielleicht jetzt mathias
middelberg stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende ex gc ist gut
kontern kann wo soll das geld herkommen
die pendlerpauschale zum beispiel soll
auf 38 cent erhöht werden pro kilometer
vielleicht kann er mittelberg das ja
aufklären
herr kruse die bemerken will ich mir
doch erlauben sie sollten sich ihre rede
vielleicht nachher nochmal im video
ansehen ich fand ehrlich dass das jetzt
richtig eine arrogante rede war das sage
ich ihnen ganz ehrlich
es war
es war ausgesprochen
überheblich gegenüber der opposition und
es war ohne irgend einen konkreten
vorschlag wie sie der situation über die
wir heute hier sprechen begegnen wollen
ich habe nicht einen einzigen konkreten
beitrag von ihnen dazu vernommen
wird die fdp ist ja in den wahlkampf
gegangen und hat versprochen es gibt
keine steuererhöhungen gibt keine
mehrbelastung und wenn sie sich die
situation jetzt ansehen sind sie voll in
diesem szenario drin sie haben massive
steuererhöhungen und zwar einfach de
facto über die kalte progression
sie haben massive mehrbelastungen für
die breite der bürger über massiv
gestiegene energiepreise
da können sie doch nicht einfach darüber
hinweggehen sie haben die stärkste
inflation seit 30 jahren das ist hier
angesprochen worden mit über 5 prozent
preissteigerung im letzten dezember und
4,9 in diesem januar und da hat leisten
sie hier keinen konkreten beitrag das
was sie bisher in die wege geleitet
haben ist das thema heizkostenzuschuss
und das war's und über den abbau der
eeg-umlage und wann sie es machen wollen
darüber diskutiert diese regierung und
auch bei der pendlerpauschale sind sich
uneins sie haben überhaupt nichts im
portfolio das ist die wahrheit kein
einziger konkreter vorschlag
ich finde dass uns das sagen offen super
arrogant gegenüber den menschen die
jetzt für jede tankfüllung 20 30 euro
mehr zahlen die pendler sind und am ende
des monats 23 und 400 euro
möglicherweise mehr für ihren berufsweg
hinlegen müssen gegenüber den
familienvätern gegenüber
alleinerziehenden die demnächst
heizkosten zu tragen haben die 1000 weit
noch darüber hinaus euro mehrkosten im
jahr betragen werden da müssen sie dem
einen oder anderen letzte hilfe gewähren
da hilft nicht der hinweis auf den
energieumbau dir her richtig ist aber
der technische umbau der findet jetzt im
laufe der jahre statt wir müssen aber
jetzt den menschen helfen die unter
diesen massiven preissteigerungen leiden
wir haben vier prozent inflation
wahrscheinlich auch in diesem jahr das
frisst jede lohnerhöhung absehbar auf
gleichzeitig wandern die leute die
arbeitnehmer die die arbeiten im
steuertarif weiter nach oben und das ist
die steuererhöhungen von der sie
versprochen haben dass sie nicht käme so
und wenn ich jetzt aber noch gekommen
ist dann ist doch die anforderungen an
sie gerade an einen fdp finanzminister
was macht er denn jetzt um die belastung
der leute auszugleichen danach fragen
doch die menschen die in diesem land sie
haben doch den tarif auf
von gepredigt jetzt hören wir nichts
mehr davon jetzt haben wir gehört dass
herr dürr ihr fraktionsvorsitzender in
der wirtschaftswoche im januar
angekündigt hat der progression bericht
soll jetzt in kürze vorgelegt werden
normalerweise mit einem herbst vorgelegt
in kürze soll er jetzt vorgelegt werden
vorgestern sagt uns der finanzminister
von diesen platz er wird jetzt doch im
herbst vorgelegt da sage ich ihnen herr
lindner hat hier mehrfach gesessen hat
gesagt er wäre ermöglichung minister
jetzt erwarten wir von ihm aber auch
dass man bei dem thema entlastung der
bürger möglichkeiten schafft
und wenn sie dann entlasten thema
heizkostenzuschuss dann sage ich ihnen
sie müssen auch gerecht entlassen sie
müssen nicht nur an die denken die
empfänger von sozialleistungen sind
sondern sie müssen vor allen dingen an
die denken die in diesem land auch
arbeiten jeden tag zur arbeit fahren die
lange wege haben auch die müssen sie
entlasten deswegen kommen sie jedenfalls
vorübergehend an einem thema wie
pendlerpauschale nicht vorbei denn nicht
jeder hat die möglichkeit auf den sv zu
wechseln und sie lassen die menschen auf
dem lande im ländlichen raum mit ihrer
politik schlichtweg im stich wie sind
mit ihrer politik verlassen
so und letzte punkt weil sie das immer
problematisieren hier das sei nicht
durchgerechnet das was wir vorgelegt
haben ist durchaus durchgerechnet die
sachen auch ganz deutlich sie haben
massive mehreinnahmen ich will nur drei
punkte nennen co2 emissionshandel
europäisch und auch national das sind
erhebliche milliarden die sie zusätzlich
an einnahmen werden sie werden mehr
einnahmen haben aus der lohnsteuer und
sie haben jetzt schon reichlich mehr
einnahmen aus der umsatzsteuer im
zweijahresvergleich dezember letztes
jahr zu zwei jahren vorher 2009/10
gerechnet über 30 prozent steigerung
alleine bei der umsatzsteuer bei diesem
thema heute geht es nicht darum dass wir
den leuten zusätzlich irgendwas
versprechen oder unsolide irgendwas zu
sagen würden sondern es geht schlichtweg
darum dass sie den menschen das
zurückgeben müssen was sie ihnen über
abgaben und steuern aus der tasche
gezogen haben das ist die wahrheit
die richter in der debatte ist der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der spd
bernd westphal weil ich vor in dem
minister ansprache ist natürlich in der
tat so dass der wirtschaftsminister ihr
nicht das wort ergreift das sind ja auch
drei anträge der oppositionsfraktionen
das ist so üblich dass man darüber dann
nicht auch als minister ans pult tritt
aber warum eigentlich nicht warum kann
man das nicht ändern und den bürgern
heute mal sagen wo man vorhat
energiepreise zu entlassen das wäre doch
mal ein guter ansatz beim westphal jetzt
muss sagen das soziale gewissen der cdu
csu fraktion das habe ich in den letzten
jahren nicht erkennen wenn weder bei
tarifbindung peter beim mindestlohn noch
bei entlassungen von arbeitnehmerinnen
und nehmer von daher ist das schon ein
stück weit schräg was sie hier
vorgetragen haben zum thema
selbstverständlich braucht es nicht den
antrag der cdu csu um sich mit den
wichtigen themen dieses landes zu
beschäftigen
das sind natürlich die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung das ist eine inflation die
getrieben ist durch energiepreise das
ist ein riesen transformationsprozess
unseres wirtschaftsstandorts deutschland
und deshalb ist es natürlich richtig
dass diese bundesregierung und das
zeichnet sich schon ab in den
koalitionsvertrag vom letzten herbst
genau mit der frage auseinandersetzt wie
kann diese gesellschaft wie kann dieser
wirtschaftsstandort aus den fossilen
aussteigen und einen weg in das
erneuerbare zeitalter aufträgen und
deshalb ist es wichtig die erneuerbaren
energien auszubauen und zwar sage ich
dass deswegen weil ich die bremser in
ihrer fraktion noch live erlebt habe bei
den vorhanden wenn es darum ging bei
wind abständen haben sie geblockt beim
ausbau der photovoltaik am see geblockt
mit einem deckel wollten sie den
versehen das waren die debatten die wir
geführt haben und deshalb ist es richtig
dass wir jetzt eine andere regierung
haben
und dass wir
und das ja wir müssen schon zu hören und
dass wir nichts machen stimmt nicht
gerade das was wir mit ihnen diskutiert
haben bei dem co2 preis bei der
entlastung der mieterinnen und mietern
war es ihre fraktion dies behindert hat
dass wir die kosten aufteilen und das
werden wir jetzt teilen diesen fehler
sie wollten dass alles den mieterinnen
und mieter auf lassen die gar keine
chance haben kommen wir zu sorgen dass
eine andere heizung im keller existiere
und natürlich muss man gucken dass es
auch seriös finanziert werden kann ich
finde das muss auch dazu gehören dass
man den haushalts spielraum nimmt und in
der verteilungsfrage dass auch gezielt
dort ansetzen wo es notwendig ist und
deshalb machen wir das genauso mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss das sind nämlich
genau diejenigen mit geringen einkommen
die wir jetzt entlasten wollen und
deshalb ist das ziel gerichtet ihre
heizung ich weiß nicht wie die aussieht
der mittelberg und deshalb ist es glaube
ich angebracht dass in der sozialen
flankierung auch sozialgericht zu machen
der zweite punkt die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage haben wir lange drüber
diskutieren ich kann mich noch an
debatten im wirtschaftsausschuss
erinnern in der letzten
legislaturperiode wir haben peter
altmaier oft aufgefordert zu sagen lasst
uns das steuern abgaben umlagen system
gerade im energiebereich
anfassen das ist nicht mehr was sich zu
der heutigen zeit und genau diese dinge
werden wir jetzt mit der abschaffung der
eeg-umlage im ersten schritt anfang und
natürlich brauchen wir in einem
zeitalter der erneuerbaren die immer
stärker im system eine bedeutung haben
auch eine andere bepreisung da gehört
strommarkt design und andere dinge mit
dazu und deshalb ist es richtig mit der
abschaffung der eeg-umlage jetzt im
sommer das richtige zeichen zu setzen
und zwar nicht nur für die privaten
haushalte sondern natürlich auch wie die
energieintensiven unternehmen die hier
in der internationalen
wettbewerbsfähigkeit auch erhalten
müssen weitere maßnahmen
werden wir auf den weg bringen und
gerade der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien wird dazu führen dass wir die
abhängigkeit von fossilen und teuren
energien dementsprechend reduzieren und
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir zum
beispiel auch den wasserstoff hochlauf
organisieren genau diese
infrastrukturmaßnahmen begleiten eine
wasserstoffwirtschaft die dazu führt
dass wir eben eine unabhängigkeit von
fossilen energien kriegen die jetzt
preistreiber sind und das ist jedenfalls
das ziel dieser regierung und zum
schluss möchte ich möchte ich noch eins
erwähnen wir haben in der erholung der
volkswirtschaft zumindest was jetzt auch
nach der pandemie ist einiges auf den
weg zu bringen und ich will noch mal
daran erinnern dass wir jetzt in einer
guten phase sind der pandemie die sich
sicherlich positiv entwickeln wird in
den nächsten wochen wir müssen alles
dafür tun dass wir nicht in eine
situation im herbst hineinstolpern die
gerade was arbeitsplätze angeht was
wirtschaftliche entwicklung angeht vor
dem gleichen dilemma stehen und deshalb
kann ich nur dazu aufrufen lassen sie
sich impfen lassen sie sich informieren
machen sie alles dafür dass wir mit der
impfkampagne weiterkommen und dann wird
auch das was frank walter steinmeier am
sonntag nochmal erwähnt hat
unterstrichen diese transformation die
wir vor uns haben die wird nur gelingen
wenn möglichst alle davon profitieren
und daran arbeitet diese ampelkoalition
herzlichen dank sagte er
auch gesagt wo die bürger und das zu
werden können also das was der minister
hier vielleicht auch hätte machen können
in der tat die fdp hat einen eigenen
antrag in dem fordert sie drei punkte
einmal absenkung der mehrwertsteuer für
ein halbes jahr des weiteren soll das
brennstoff emissionshandel gesetz außer
kraft gesetzt werden und dann fordert
die fdp von der bundesregierung dass die
preisauszeichnung an tankstellen nur
einmal täglich um 12 uhr vorgenommen
werden darf wird spaniel für die afd er
ist der verkehrspolitischen sprecher
wir haben rekordpreise für kraftstoffe
und eine energie preisbedingte inflation
von offiziell über fünf prozent aber das
sind alles ja keine naturereignisse das
ist das ergebnis einer politik die nicht
in der lage ist die folgen des eigenen
handelns abzuschätzen und da muss ich
jetzt mal in die union gucken das was
wir hier sehen das ist doch nichts
anderes als die von ihnen verursachte
situation durch ihre eigenen gesetze
haben sie in den letzten jahren ja diese
situation geschaffen und wir haben vor
genau dieser preissteigerung von
kraftstoffen energiepreisen in diesem
plenum hier permanent gewarnt wie haben
sie darauf aufmerksam gemacht und jetzt
haben sie das ergebnis ihrer politik der
letzten jahre aber ich will mal ganz
konkret auf ihren antrag eingehen fast
alles habe ich ja schon gesagt was sie
darin beklagen ist ausschließlich durch
sie und ihre gesetze verursacht auch die
gesetze der spd natürlich und mir ist
aufgefallen dass wesentliche teile ihres
antrags den haben sie so ein bisschen
unseren afd anträgen der letzten
legislatur so ein bisschen der bom
konkret haben wir bereits im dezember ja
eine erhöhung der kilometerpauschale
gefordert und sie haben wir sogar
unseren zahlen werden von 38 cent pro
kilometer übernommen also vielen dank
dafür dass sie das hier einträgen und
verstanden haben in der gleichen debatte
habe ich auch erstmalig auf die
unverschämte co2 besteuerung der co2
freien kraftstoff anteile bin ich hier
auch eingegangen und auch das finde ich
in ihrem antrag wieder finde ich toll
dass sie unsere sachen so aufgreifen
aber
gut ihr sammelsurium an punkten bleibt
stückwerk in der jetzigen ja das weiß
ich aber es bleibt jetzt trotzdem so in
der jetzigen situation hilft es
jedenfalls nicht und das muss ich ihnen
jetzt mal sagen mit schaufenster
anträgen die aufgebrachte bevölkerung
etwas zu beruhigen was die bürger in
diesem land brauchen ist eine
fundamentale umkehr von einer durch und
durch ideologisch verblendeten wünsch
dir was politik
co2 reduktion um jeden preis co2
reduktion um jeden preis ist für viele
und unserem land unbezahlbar und die
umverteilungs maßnahmen die sowohl von
der eu aus ihrem werkzeugkasten
aufgeführt werden als auch die ansätze
der linken sind planwirtschaft und dach
hat noch nie funktioniert
und wenn sie liebe kollegen von der
union wenn sie eine tatsächliche
entlastung der bürger in diesem land
wollen sind wir auch gerne bereit mit
ihnen gemeinsam initiativen hier in
diesem parlament einzubringen aber ich
glaube die zusammenarbeit mit uns die
haben sie sich ja selber verboten herr
kollege würden sie denn eine
zwischenfrage aus der union für sie
verständlich
ja gab der spanier ja wir arbeiten nicht
mit ihnen zusammen weil wir in einem
punkt fundamental andere frage meinung
sind und das will ich in einer frage
formulieren glauben sie wirklich die
politik der bisherigen bundesregierung
ist dafür verantwortlich dass überall in
der welt die energiepreise insbesondere
die fossilen energiepreise und wieso ist
die bundesregierung als die bisherige
bundesregierung schuld daran dass
russland jetzt nur das gas liefert dass
die vertraglich zugesagt hat und nicht
wie in den vergangenen jahren mehr warum
ist das schult der bundesregierung und
nicht ein weltweites phänomen
vielen dank da bin ich gerne darauf
eingehen zunächst auf die energiepolitik
und
die versorgung mit russischem gas es ist
natürlich richtig dass einerseits
weltmarktpreise gibt aber andererseits
und das muss ich jetzt ja auch mal hier
sagen andererseits ist es ja so dass
nord stream 2 eine gasversorgung für
deutschland sicher stellt und wie er das
sind wir ja auch immer der meinung dass
wir diese gasversorgung brauchen und wir
müssen hier an dieser stelle auch mal
klar sagen wenn die russen und gas
liefern zu vereinbarten konditionen da
gibt es da doch überhaupt nichts dran zu
kritisieren und jetzt komme ich aber
noch mal auf die
energiepreissteigerungen die sie
ansprechen es ist doch schon
verwunderlich wenn sie genau hingucken
wie die kraftstoffpreise nur die reden
wir hier konkret die rohölpreise in der
welt die waren schon höher als jetzt
wesentlich höher aber die
kraftstoffpreise in diesem land die
waren noch nie höher als jetzt und das
liegt eben ganz wesentlich an der von
ihnen herbeigeführten co2 steuer doch da
brauchen sie nicht im kopf steht und da
können sie nach guten da gibt es jede
menge statistiken noch nie waren die
kraftstoffpreise höher obwohl wir schon
höhere rohölpreise am weltmarkt hatten
das heißt diese argumentation diese
argumentation dass die weltmarktpreise
bei uns das hier diktieren die ist
einfach nicht richtig und das kann jeder
nachvollziehen der im internet google
wenn sie mir kommentierungen geben
wollen dann müssen wir das leider über
eine zwischenfrage machen aber so nicht
es ist niemandem damit geholfen wenn wir
hier in deutschland versuchen die welt
zu retten und uns dabei selbst ruinieren
und deshalb können wir auch ihrem antrag
in der jetzigen form so leider nicht
zustimmen bitte ich um verständnis aber
wie gesagt das angebot steht kommen wir
doch einfach mal zusammen und machen
eine vernünftige politik für die
menschen in diesem land damit die
menschen sich in diesem land das leben
wieder leisten können vielen dank
[Applaus]
der bundestag debattiert über drei
anträge der oppositionsfraktionen
es geht um die energiepreise und der
nächste redner kommt von den
bündnisgrünen andreas dresch
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
millionen menschen in deutschland haben
gerade angst vor der nächsten
stromrechnung sie haben angst vor der
nächsten gasrechnung und diese menschen
brauchen unterstützung weil die fossilen
energien gerade massiv die preise nach
oben treiben das was sie vorgelegt haben
liebe union ist leider das exakte
gegenteil keinerlei gezielte maßnahmen
nichts dergleichen und gleichzeitig
viele viele teure steuergeschenke
die haben und nichts mit
haushaltsdisziplin die haben nichts mit
solider haushaltsführung zu tun und das
ist das einzige was ich hier einbringen
können wissen sie ich mach mal zwei
beispiele ich mache nur zwei beispiele
wissen sie was es kostet die
umsatzsteuer auf strom und gas zu senken
für die zwei jahre die sie vorschlagen
18 milliarden euro das ist das was sie
da rein geschrieben haben dass es nicht
dass es tatsächlich nicht so finanzieren
das treibt gleichzeitig die fossile
inflation dass es das was sie damit
bezwecken und vor allem ist kommt bei
den leuten nicht an das ist doch völlig
klar und wenn dann der cdu-vorsitzende
noch zusätzlich dachte wir müssen die
spritsteuer senken glauben sie dass
kommt eins zu eins an der tankstelle an
nichts wird der gleichen passieren was
passiert ist dass die schecks ausstellen
können an gazprom an exxonmobil das ist
eine politik einer fossilen inflation
mit der gießkanne die es mit uns nicht
geben herr otto es gibt keine
zwischenfragen hund ausführen möchten
sie den demnach in ein zweites beispiel
die pendlerpauschale kostet wieder
milliarden euro nutzt als steuerliche
abschreibung gerade dienen mit den
großen einkommen und das wichtigste weil
sie sagen akute unterstützung akut ist
das nicht es wird dann relevant wenn die
steuererklärung im nächsten jahr dann
kommt das ist keine akute unterstützung
deswegen wird auch hier ein muster
deutlich hemmungslos milliarden aus dem
fenster schmeißen und zwar so dass vor
allem die mit dem meisten geld
profitieren und gleichzeitig die
mineralöl- konzerne dass das muss man so
sagen ist keine sinnvolle politik und
genau deswegen werden wir das so nicht
mitmachen
stattdessen stattdessen und das muss man
sagen geht es um gezielte maßnahmen das
ist das was jetzt ist die finanzierbar
und umsetzbar sind der
heizkostenzuschuss erstens dann sofort
zuschlag für kinder und jugendliche und
für alle in der grundsicherung braucht
es eine schnelle einmalzahlung um
menschen aus der größten finanziellen
not zu holen das ist das was jetzt
braucht und wissen sie
und wissen sie dass wir stehen mit
diesen punkten beileibe nicht alleine in
der anzahl anfang der woche hat ein
dutzend sozialverbände in der
öffentlichkeit genau das geforderte sind
rausgegangen weil not am mann und der
frau ist und wir jetzt solche lösungen
brauchen zweitens hat clemens fuß vom
ifo-institut genau das gefordert auf die
bedürftigen haushalte konzentrieren und
auch sozialtransfers anpassen die cdu
geführte regierung in nrw bringt im
bundesrat am 11 februar einen antrag an
den schließungs antrag ein und fordert
eine einmalzahlung für alle menschen in
der grundsicherung bei ihnen finde ich
nichts keinerlei gezielte maßnahme namen
gezielte maßnahmen das ist das was wir
wollen sie haben keinen machbares
konzept wir sagen langfristig raus aus
der fossilen inflation raus aus den
fossilen energien rein in die
erneuerbaren und jetzt gezielt
unterstützen das ist politik sie sinn
macht und die funktioniert dankeschön
wir kommen zu einer kurzintervention des
kollegen springer von der alb die
fraktion
sagt wir sind sehr wohl mit ein in einem
diskurs mit ihnen sind auch daran
interessiert diesen diskurs zu
intensivieren unsere hand ist
ausgestreckt und wir hoffen dass
und heute haben sie es noch mal
wiederholt dass der steuersenkungen auch
spritpreise von den unternehmen nicht
weitergegeben werden würden da möchte
ich darauf hinweisen dass wir das in
polen während wir hier noch debattieren
und im grunde nichts passiert niemand
entlastet wird die konservative
regierung in polen tatsächlich die
steuern auf die sprit preise gesenkt hat
der sprit in polen kostet ungefähr 60
cent weniger inzwischen als in
deutschland ich weiß dass ich komme aus
ostbrandenburg jeder in meinem umfeld
fährt inzwischen nach polen zum tanken
und die tankstellen landschaft in
ostbrandenburg geht gerade den bach
runter wenn sie also dieses argument
anführen die preise werden die
entlastung werden nicht weitergegeben
aber polen zeigt dass das geht sind sie
bereit ihren standpunkt zu überdenken
und vielleicht doch eine senkung der
steuern auf spritpreise in betracht zu
ziehen danke schön herr
tritt zur antwort bitte schön
jetzt geht's los ich kann das an der
stelle sehr sehr kurz machen zu einer
wehrhaften demokratie
gehört es auch mit bestimmten
gruppierungen nicht zu sprechen dass der
grundsatz
und das bedeutet für mich dass sich mit
rechtsextremisten nicht spreche mit
rechtsextremisten nicht in einen
politischen dialog gehe und insofern ist
das auch das einzige was ich ihnen an
dieser stelle als antwort übermitteln
kann danke schön
wenn ich zur rede punkt von der fdp
maximilian mordhorst der fdp
bundesfinanzminister hat ja sich dafür
eingesetzt die eeg-umlage im sommer
abzuschaffen das wirtschaftsministerium
prüft das im moment ob es so kommt
werden wir dann sehen
humoristischen geradezu vielleicht
aggressiven zwischenruf auch aus der
unionsfraktion wundern denn wir reden
hier über ein wahnsinnig ernstes thema
wir reden darüber ob der
oberstufenschüler der vielleicht sein
erstes auto hat und auf dem land wohnt
am ende des monats noch zur schule kommt
wir reden darüber ob der student der in
seiner ersten wohnungen wohnt mit den
stromkosten ein immer größeres problem
hat oder nicht und wir reden darüber ob
arbeitnehmer bis zum rentner in
deutschland angst haben müssen vor der
nächsten heiz und nebenkosten
abrechnungen das ist ein ernstes thema
und deswegen werden wir das haben wir
angekündigt als ampelkoalition auch
handeln dass sie so tun als würden wir
keine vorschläge machen als würden wir
den nichts entgegensetzen ist blanker
hohn wir machen vorschläge ohne ende und
deswegen ja wir können darüber jetzt
einmal kurz sprechen wir haben ja auch
ein krieg ums fremming denen sie lieber
führen als um die sache an sich die
einen sprechen von grüner inflation die
anderen von fossiler inflation man muss
sagen beides ist richtig ja es sind die
vor allem die rohstoffpreise die steigen
und die zurzeit dazu führen dass die
verbraucherpreise sich immer weiter
erhöhen und deswegen müssen wir
langfristig die energiewende so auf den
weg bekommen dass wir die unabhängigkeit
von möglichst einzelnen energieträgern
hin bekommen wir müssen bei der
übergangstechnologie gas auch davon
reden ob wir es endlich schaffen
abhängigkeiten von einzelnen staaten in
den griff zu bekommen und solche
debatten wie das lng terminal werden wir
führen der sie sind sie müssen
strategisch langfristig betrachtet
werden das haben wir in der
vergangenheit beispielsweise bei den
german brunsbüttel aus meiner sicht
nicht ausreichend getan herr kollege
anderen den wunsch nach einer
zwischenfrage aus der fraktion die linke
möchten sie das bitte schön
vielen dank frau präsidentin vielen dank
herr kollege dass sie die zwischenfrage
zu lassen es sind zwei fragen die erste
frage sie sprachen lng terminals zu
lassen ist ihm bekannt dass allen chicas
insbesondere aus den usa gefragt erst
mal klimaschädliches und zweitens
deutlich teureres als viele andere
energieform zu der die erste frage die
zweite frage ich sie sprachen gerade von
den kosten die explosion und das stimmt
und explodieren tun aber auch die
gewinne von energiekonzern vattenfall
neue meldung 4,6 milliarden gewinnen
juniper korrigiert gewinnprognose nach
oben e.on verdoppelt den gewinn auf 2,2
milliarden die energiekonzerne haben in
den letzten fünf jahren ihre gewinne
verdreifacht
das sind die realität und das ist ohne
die preis explosion im dezember/januar
die noch einmal zu weiteren gewinnsprung
geführt das sind sie deswegen nicht der
meinung wie wir das zum schutz der
verbraucherinnen verbraucher dringend
eine energiepreis aufsicht notwendig ist
dass es dringend erforderlich ist diese
gewinne einzuschränken abzukassieren
damit wir eben diese gewinne nutzen um
die energiekosten für die bevölkerung
für die unternehmen zu senken lieber
kollege ich finde das immer wahnsinnig
interessant natürlich ist das eine
brückentechnologie und über
umweltprobleme brauchen wir gar nicht
lange zu sprechen bei russland fällt
ihnen das aber irgendwie nie ein und
dann auf der anderen seite davon zu
sprechen dass man als reaktion auf eine
wirklich problematische inflation mehr
aussichten haben möchte league ob der
geld verteilen möchte an alle möglichen
haushalte das ist nicht das gegenmittel
zur inflation solche aktionen können der
grund für inflation seien und deswegen
ist das nicht hilfreich sondern eher
problematisch auch die vorschläge die
sie in ihrem antrag unterbreiten
zum anderen teil ich habe gerade über
fossile oder grüne inflation gesprochen
zum anderen teil natürlich sind die
steigenden rohstoffpreise dieser zu
führen auf der anderen seite sind wir
und das müssen wir uns eingestehen sind
die anteile an den preisen beim strom
beim benzin zu einem großen teil
staatlich zu einem großen prozentsatz
besteht das aus steuern und abgaben und
neben der tatsache dass wir die
eeg-umlage zeitnahe abschaffen wollen
als es die union überhaupt vorhatte mit
der tatsache dass wir den
einkommensteuertarif haben wir gestern
darüber gesprochen auf basis progression
berichts anpassen werden und mit den
zuschüssen die wir auf den weg bringen
zusätzlich müssen wir auch langfristig
wenn wir mit dem co2 preis so
weitermachen wo ich hier bin denn wir
müssen den klimawandel stoppen über das
nebeneinander von verbrauchssteuern und
co2 preis sprechen denn das
nebeneinander kann nur kurzfristig nicht
langfristig funktionieren ich bin der
überzeugung wir sollten den weg den wir
jetzt haben vernünftig beschreiten ich
finde ja interessant was sie jetzt alles
neu auf den weg bringen wollen ich hab
da so ein bisschen vielleicht auch eine
andere perspektive weil ich 25 bin und
vor menschen stehe von der union die
mich einen großen teil meines gesamten
lebens bisher fast durchgängig regiert
haben und jetzt auf einmal mit den
vorschlägen um die ecke kommen die sie
16 jahre nicht ins land gebracht haben
in unterschiedlichsten konstellationen
in unterschiedlichen mehrheiten mit
unterschiedlichen prozent setzen und die
krone auf die setzen sie nicht der
kollege rudi hat zur konkreten antrag
schon ausgerechnet arbeitet die krone
setzte dem ganzen mal wieder die csu auf
wir haben das mal ausgerechnet wegen
programm sie hatten ja auch schon tollen
zwischenruf herr dobrindt mit super
schwachsinn passt zu diesem programm
deutschland in der mitte halten wir
haben das mal ausgerechnet was das so
bis 2026 kosten würde
kinderfreibetrag soll auf den
grundfreibetrag angehoben werden 8,1
milliarden generation vor 14 milliarden
anleihe mit zwei prozent garantiezins 18
milliarden mütter rente 319 milliarden
senkungen energie steuern 90 milliarden
home office pauschale 23,8 milliarden
und und und wir sind auf eine summe am
ende des tages bis 2026 von um und bei
300 milliarden euro gekommen nebenbei
noch viele sachen die man nicht genau
beziffern kann ohne einen gegen
finanzierungsvorschlag noch besser davor
steht sogar noch ein haushaltsvorbehalt
also wie man das seriös umsetzen soll
kann ich den menschen nicht vermitteln
ich möchte es ihnen auch nicht
vermitteln denn wir werden das handeln
gegen machen vernünftig finanziert ich
komme zum schluss und ich bin sehr froh
dass wir das jetzt endlich nach dieser
langen zeit auf den weg bringen können
vielen dank
300 milliarden meine damen und herren
das ist tatsächlich sehr viel geld man
muss sich allerdings fragen warum
deutschland die teuersten energiepreise
in europa hat vielleicht sollte man da
ansetzen der nächste redner kommt von
der cdu/csu ist sprecher für
verbraucherschutz volker ullrich der
bundestag debattiert hier über die
energiepreise und über die möglichen
senkungen anträge von cdu csu von der
linken und von der fdp liegen dem hause
fuhr
oder afg natürlich nicht der fdp pardon
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren
die menschen erwarten ganz konkrete und
schnell wirksame lösungen in bezug auf
die steigenden gas und energiepreise
nicht wenige fragen sich was ist
bezahlbaren die warme wohnung oder der
sportunterricht für die kinder 40
prozent steigerung bei energiepreisen
bedeutet eine neue soziale frage aber
auch für unternehmen in der glas-
keramik- und druckindustrie ist die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit längst gefährdet ja
mehr es stehen arbeitsplätze ganz
konkret auf dem spiel wer jetzt bei den
hohen energiepreisen nicht sofort
handelt muss sich vorwerfen lassen die
menschen und die arbeitsplätze im stich
zu lassen wir brauchen schnell wirksame
lösungen
die bundesregierung ist nicht ursächlich
für die hohen energiepreise aber wenn
sie jetzt nicht handelt wird sie
verantwortlich werden wenn sie jetzt
nicht alles in die wege leiten und die
preise zu senken
dann ist der einkommensverlust der
mittelschicht ihre soziale kälte in
diesem land
die vorschläge die sie auf den tisch
gelegt haben reichen nicht aus der
heizkostenzuschuss ist zu wenig und so
ungenau dass klima geld das eines tages
kommen soll ist überhaupt nicht ab
ministriert weil sie nicht wissen wie
sie das geld der menschen zurückgeben
können entscheidend ist dass wir dort
ansetzen wo es sofort wirksam ist dass
die menschen sofort etwas davon haben
und spüren dass der staat sie bei den
stein energiekosten entlastet das ist
der kern unseres antrags was wollen wir
wir wollen die stromsteuer auf das
europäische minimum senken wir wollen
die umsatzsteuer von 19 auf sieben
prozent für energieleistungen absenken
wir wollen die energie die abschlag von
eeg umlage vorziehen wir wollen aber
auch regulatorisch sicherstellen dass
die energieversorgungsunternehmen
diese absenkungen auch an ihre kunden
weitergeben dass es regulatorisch
möglich und das wird eine ganz klare und
deutliche entlastung bedeuten herr
kollege es gibt den wunsch nach einer
zwischenfrage aus der aktion möchte sich
zu lassen
nein
es geht aber auch um die konkreten
vertragsbeziehungen von verbrauchern zu
ihren energielieferanten
wir haben den letzten monaten
festgestellt dass viele billig
stromanbieter und billig dass anbieter
von heute auf morgen gekündigt haben
dass oftmals die post des
grundversorgers im briefkasten war und
damit eine bis zu 200 prozentige
erhöhung im raum stand es muss
sichergestellt werden durch regulierung
das stromanbieter nicht von heute auf
morgen kündigen können dass eine
kündigungsfrist gibt und dass
stromanbieter gerade im
niedrigpreissegment auch solide und
seriös sind dass das geschäftsmodell
trägt dass jemand der auf eine lieferung
vertraut diese lieferung auch erhält das
muss diese bundesregierung durch
regulierung sicherstellen
und
bei aller wertschätzung auch für die
lokalen stromversorger
wir müssen noch mal im kartellrecht an
die frage herangehen inwieweit eine zu
große spreizung zwischen grundtarif
normaltarif tatsächlich angebracht ist
die menschen müssen darauf vertrauen
können dass die
senkungen im bereich der energiepreise
sofort ankommen das entbindet uns nicht
von der langfristigen pflicht die neue
bahn energien auszubauen aber jetzt geht
es um ganz konkrete entlastungen weil
die menschen angesichts steigender
energiepreise ganz konkrete
befürchtungen haben und diese müssen wir
jetzt lösen bitte stimmen sie unserem
antrag zu
[Applaus]
der kollege andreas mehltretter für die
spd fraktion kommt heute hier zu seiner
ersten reaktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen niemand
darf sich abend heizen müssen das steht
außer frage viele menschen können sich
aber die steigenden heizkosten nicht
leisten
dagegen müssen wir etwas tun es ist gut
dass wir uns an dieser stelle alle einig
sind wer erleben gerade eine krise der
fossilen energieerzeugung weltweit die
konjunktur zieht wieder an die
rohstoffpreise steigen
geopolitische konflikte verschärfen die
situation
wir sind das führt uns gerade diese
situation sehr deutlich vor augen immer
noch viel zu abhängig von fossilen
energieträgern
sind diese fossilen energieträger vor
allem das erdgas die für die
sprunghaften preisanstieg verantwortlich
sind es ist eben nicht nur
klimapolitisch notwendig die
erneuerbaren schnell auszubauen es ist
auch sinnvoll für eine sichere
energieversorgung und es entlastet den
geldbeutel der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher
erneuerbare energien sind mittlerweile
günstiger als alle fossilen
energieträger von atomkraft ganz zu
schweigen wenn wir mittelfristig stabile
und günstige energiepreise haben wollen
geht das nur indem wir die erneuerbaren
energien ausbauen
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir in der
ampelkoalition auf eine schnelle
energiewende setzen erneuerbare energien
statt gas und kohle darum geht es
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich komme
aus dem bundesland in dem die csu den
ausbau der windenergie mit der 10h
regelung fast komplett gestoppt hat es
ist die blockade haltung der union die
dafür verantwortlich ist dass wir bei
den erneuerbaren noch nicht weiter sind
und dass uns die steigenden preise bei
fossilen energien jetzt vor so große
probleme stellen
auch bei einer gebäudesanierung haben
sie liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
verloren immer gebremst das ergebnis
waren zu wenig ambitionierte und
unterfinanzierte förderprogramme wir
brauchen aber eine renovierung offensive
die heizkosten für ein gebäude der
schlechtesten effizienzklasse h sind
heute zehn mal so hoch wie die für ein
gebäude mit der besten effizienzklasse
a+ ohne gebäudesanierungen zahlen die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
weiterhin zu hohe preise
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union nachdem sie also jahrelang dafür
gesorgt haben dass zu wenig passiert ist
um energie günstig und unsere gebäude
effizient zu machen kommen sie jetzt mit
so einem sammelsurium an
zusammenhangslose maß nur mit namen um
zu kaschieren dass sie im
wirtschaftsministerium in den letzten
jahren leider wenig auf die reihe
bekommen haben
klar kann man nach dem gießkannenprinzip
möglichst viele forderungen in einen
antrag schreiben und natürlich kann man
für 40 milliarden euro forderungen
aufstellen ohne zu sagen wo denn das
geld dafür herkommen soll man hat sich
dann aber von konstruktiver politik
komplett verabschiedet meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
der rasante anstieg der gaspreise griff
die haushalte am stärksten die geringe
einkommen haben und in schlecht
gedämmten wohnungen leben dort muss die
hilfe ankommen dafür müssen wir sagen
statt gezielt zu entlasten fordern sie
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von union
aber ineffiziente und teure maßnahmen
die wie zb bei der pendlerpauschale auch
noch klimapolitisch falsche anreize
setzen es ist wirklich gut dass sie von
der regierungs auf die oppositionsbank
gewechselt sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
brauchen eine perspektive für echte
unabhängigkeit von steigenden energie
rohstoffpreisen und deswegen passieren
wir eine schnelle energiewende
vorhersehbar steigende preise für
fossile energieträger haben dabei eine
wichtige lenkungswirkung
gleichzeitig haben wir auch aber immer
gesagt dass es einen schutz vor
überforderung durch zu schnell steigende
preise geben muss und die preise steigen
es hat einfach zu schnell deshalb
brauchen wir jetzt auch soforthilfen es
ist richtig dass wir heute den
heizkostenzuschuss für menschen mit
niedrigen einkommen auf den weg bringen
es ist richtig dass die bundesregierung
gerade prüft die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage vorzuziehen und es ist
richtig darüber zu diskutieren wie wir
plötzliche vertragskündigungen und den
rückfall in teure grundversorgung
verändern liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir brauchen sofort helfen und wir
brauchen eine perspektive für niedrigere
heizkosten und bezahlbare energie beides
werden wir anpacken nicht mit der
gießkanne sondern mit gezielten
maßnahmen
war das für unser gebiet zu den preisen
zudem ist gerade
aus den oppositionsfraktionen gibt denn
die pandemie hat natürlich nicht nur
gesundheitliche auswirkungen sondern
auch finanzielle
überziehen das war eben gerade gar nicht
nötig aber auch dass es keine
zwischenfrage gibt das ist auch sofort
akzeptiert worden ich wollte es noch
einmal für alle sagen und gebe jetzt
gerne dem kollegen bernard herrmann das
wort auch zu seiner ersten rede für
bündnis 90 die grünen hier
neutronen von bundestagsvize präsidentin
katrin göring eckardt dass bei der
ersten rede die redner nicht gleich
durch zwischenfragen unterbrochen werden
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
steigenden energiepreise sind ganz klar
das ergebnis politischer fehler
entscheidung der letzten jahre und
jahrzehnte wir erleben eine dadurch
verschuldete fossil inflation es wurde
verschlafen den ausbau erneuerbarer
energien voranzutreiben
die bedeutung energetischer
modernisierung wurde and gänze verkannt
die wucht dieser fossilen
versorgungskrise hätte abgefedert werden
können
es überrascht mich daher nicht im
geringsten dass die cdu csu in ihrem
antrag kaum ein wort darüber verliert
sie sehr geehrte cdu csu haben die
energie und wärme wende verschlafen
die lunte
so nun beklagten preis explosion haben
sie doch selbst gelegt
wir sind uns einig dass steigende
strompreise und heizkosten für sehr
viele menschen zur schweren belastung
werden betroffen sind menschen geringen
einkommens aber immer mehr auch die
mittelschicht
dringend nötige kurzfristige maßnahmen
kommen und das gezielt und das ist
richtig so
lassen sie mich aber
einen wesentlichen aspekt an dieser
stelle ergänzen wenn wir über steigende
heizkosten sprechen dann müssen wir
zugleich die geringe modernisierungs
rate von gebäuden in den blick nehmen
gebäudezustand und energiekosten gehören
doch untrennbar zusammen mehr als ein
drittel des gesamten deutschen in der
endenergieverbrauchs erfolgt im
gebäudesektor etwa zwei drittel aller
wohngebäude wurden vor dem inkrafttreten
der ersten wärmeschutzverordnung vor 43
jahren errichtet sie sind oft schlecht
gedämmt und verbrauchen bis zu fünfmal
mehr energie als neubauten die förderung
gehört in den bestand
unbestreitbar können im gebäudebereich
enorme einsparpotenziale beim
energieverbrauch erreicht werden die
neue bundesregierung richtet auch dazu
den blick nach vorne wir packen die
energetische modernisierung in dieser
legislaturperiode endlich an ab 223 wird
ein neues förderprogramm zum
klimafreundlichen modernisieren und
bauen aufgelegt und ganzheitlicher
betrachtung jede neu eingebaute heizung
soll ab 225 auf basis von 65 prozent
erneuerbare energien betrieben werden
besorgen endlich für mehr
energieeffizienz
beim ausbau erneuerbarer energien sind
wir schon jetzt aktiv das bmw k hat in
seiner eröffnungsbilanz die schritte
vorgegeben und wird bereits bis zum
sommer die erforderlichen weichen
stellen für das ausbauziel 80 prozent
erneuerbaren strom bis 2030 und damit
sorgen wir für eine sichere saubere und
einzig noch langfristig bezahlbare
energieversorgung
der ausweg der fossilen versorgungskrise
lässt sich nur mit einem raschen ausbau
der erneuerbaren erreichen und um eines
klarzustellen nicht in zehn jahren
werden erneuerbare preiswerter seien
bereits heute ist es die preiswerter was
sie auch daran erkennen dass sie im
januar an den energiebörsen in
frankreich 1 10 cent teuren strompreis
gegenüber deutschland hatten alles
einschlägig da wir packen jetzt an und
stellen jetzt um schnellstmöglich und
engagiert ja wir packen die vor uns
liegenden herausforderungen an sozial
gerecht für ein gutes langfristig
bezahlbares leben für uns aber auch dass
unsere kinder enkel und urenkel
vielen dank
das war dann die erste rede von und
hermann von den bündnisgrünen im
deutschen bundestag und auf ihm direkt
antworten wird andreas jung der sprecher
für klimaschutz und energie der
unionsfraktion auch die unionsfraktion
hat hier einen antrag eingereicht in dem
sie fordern die explosion bei den
energiepreisen zu bekämpfen und zeitnah
wirksam und gerechten zu entlasten
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das erste wort an die redner
der afg in der tat wir werden mit ihm
niemals zusammen kommen weil wir als
christdemokraten wert überzeugung haben
die uns fundamental von ihnen trennen
das gilt ganz generell und auch in
dieser frage haben wir eine andere
haltung wir haben eine andere analyse
die explosion der energiepreise liegt
nicht an den kosten der erneuerbaren in
deutschland die liegt an einem hunger
nach fossiler energie weltweit und
deshalb ist es ja auch keine entwicklung
die sich nur bei uns im land stellt hier
auch schon die uns international
beschäftigt das ist ein erheblicher
unterschied schon in der analyse und
deshalb teilen wir die überzeugung dass
die mittel und langfristige antwort der
beschleunigte ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien ist energieeffizienz maßnahmen
sind im stück für stück unabhängig zu
werden von fossiler energie das ist
richtig den weg muss man gehen wir
werden alles was in diese richtung geht
und vernünftig ist unterstützen und wir
fangen dass das was jetzt auf den weg
gebracht werden muss bei der
energieeffizienz auch beherzt angegangen
wird nach dem viel porzellan zerschlagen
wurde bei der kfw gebäudesanierung
brauchen wir jetzt klarheit wie sind die
regeln für den neubau bei effizienten
neubauten wie sie die regeln bei den
turnier bei den sanierungen der reichen
nicht politische absichtserklärung der
minister wir brauchen erst klarheit
gebrauchen vermessen verlässlichkeit wir
brauchen regeln auf die man sich stützen
kann zu denen man anträge stellen und
dann ist ein kollege möchten sie denn
eine zwischenfrage aus der armee
fraktion zu lassen
bitte bitte schön
danke für ein herr kollege herr kollege
jungen für das zu lassen zwischenfrage
zunächst
meine großmutter fliegt dazu sagen man
soll nie nie sagen das einfach mal
vorneweg die geschichte hat auch da
tatsächlich die bestätigt die das sagen
zweiter sprechen sie nicht lieber doch
von grüner inflation und ich glaube wir
fangen gar nicht erst an den klimafragen
mit ihm zu reden wenn sie ihren
grundlegenden fehler einräumen würden
sie das dann tun hals über kopf rein
biologisch und populistisch getrieben
aus der kernenergie nach fukushima
ausgetreten zu sein zweitens frage ich
sie würden sie ein wollen dass der
dämpfer in deutschland und jüngst im
handelsblatt und in vielen anderen guten
publikationen konnte man entnehmen dass
die erstens ineffizient sind und
zweitens natürlich der kollege von der
spd hat natürlich auch so gesagt wird
dämmen das muss dann nämlich auch der
armen mieter bezahlen denn irgendwann
muss es bezahlen oder sonst der
vermieter der böse bezahlen da schon gar
nicht mehr motiviert ist in berlin
überhaupt wohnungen zu bauen drittens
würden sie mir eigentlich bin ich ein
bisschen älter ds benzin hat auch ihre
partei seit über 30 jahren zum stopfen
von finanzlöchern erst war es wir
erhöhen den benzinpreis für die rente
danke für die umwelt für jeden mist kam
sie tatsächlich den benzinpreis
herbeigezogen haben den autofahrern über
die rübe gezogen um es mal ganz
klassisch zu formulieren und viertens
finanzierten würden sie eigentlich auch
bestätigen dass im prinzip der
strompreis in deutschland nicht deshalb
so hoch ist weil grün so schön ist
sondern weil wir auch hier die
querfinanzierung der sogenannten
erneuerbaren vorgenommen haben denn wir
haben den höchsten höchsten strompreis
weltweit und dh nichts mit der
preisentwicklung zu tun sondern mit
ihrer ideologisch getriebenen
energiewende wir haben den höchsten
energie passen sie hoffentlich das
würden wenn sie über das beantworten
würden wäre ich ihnen sehr dankbar die
vier zwischen
dass es keine zwischenfragen sind eher
eine grundsatzerklärung zur
unterschiedlichen energie und
klimapolitischen fragen ich gehe da auf
gerne ein möchte aber darauf hinweisen
dass sich die redezeiten uhr einiges
verlängern wird
erstens nein heißt nein und auch gerade
wegen unserer geschichte und unseren
wert überzeugen wir werden mit ihnen
niemals zusammen kommen das kann ich ihm
ins stammbuch schreiben
zweitens ja wir haben nach fukushima die
entscheidung getroffen aus der
kernenergie
auszusteigen
das war nicht aus ideologischen aus
guten gründen weil sich gezeigt hat dass
die kernenergie ein restrisiko mit sich
bringt es sich dort verwirklicht hat
dieses restrisiko ein tsunami wie dort
so was ist in deutschland nicht zu
erwarten aber auch hier was ein
restrisiko und deshalb hat man ja nicht
nicht irgendwas übers knie gebrochen
sind hat eine kommission eingesetzt die
sich damit beschäftigt hat ob es die
möglichkeit gibt
energieform voran zu bringen die diese
risiken nicht bringen und deshalb
sollten das ja nicht sofort abgestellt
sein er hat gesagt wir nehmen uns einen
zeitraum von zehn jahren in dem wir
schritt für schritt abstellen werden
indem wir auch lösungen
finden wollen zur frage der
endlagersuche tragen sie mal zur lösung
dieser fragen bei damit haben wir uns in
kommission im bundestag beschäftigt wenn
man zwischen bundesrat und bundesrat
beschäftigt um die schwierige frage zu
lösen wo kommen diese stoffe hin die für
viele generationen noch risiken mit sich
bringen würden und deshalb unterstrich
diese entscheidung war nicht ideologisch
sie war richtig und wir halten daran
fest
dann haben sie angesprochen die frage
der verteilung der co2 kosten auf
vermieter und mieter und da will ich
sagen wir müssen uns das genau angucken
aber mir scheint auf den ersten blick
das was die regierung jetzt vorlegt ein
vernünftiger weg zu sein und es ist
übrigens ein anderer das sagt an die
adresse von west vor allen anderen in
der spd es ist ein anderer als der den
sie noch vor wenigen monaten in der
regierung vorgeschlagen haben sie haben
gesagt wir machen immer die verteilung
50 vermieter 50 meter und wir haben
gesagt es ist doch nicht gerecht es wird
im klimaschutz nicht gerecht weil es
muss doch eine rolle spielen ob ein
vermieter ein haus saniert eine wohnung
voranbringen alles was er tut macht oder
ob es eben nicht macht und dass der der
nix macht dann gleich viel bezahlen soll
wie der der alles gemacht hat das kann
nicht richtig sein deshalb finde ich es
richtig zu sagen wir knüpfen an den
sanierungs zustand der wohnung an den
vermieter der viel getan hat der macht
weniger und muss weniger bezahlen und
einer der eben nicht saniert der muss
mehr tun und umgekehrt wird damit auch
ein
dass mieter vermieter fällen ist zu
einem gerechten ausgleich gebracht das
werden wir uns genau angucken aber es
scheint die richtige richtung zu gehen
dann will ich weil ich sehe dass wir
eine redezeit weiterläuft kommen zu der
frage die hier angesprochen wird wie
sind die maßnahmen zu finanzieren die
wir hier vorschlagen und ich will ihnen
sagen das was die ampel regierung in
diesem jahr plant das ist der
heizkostenzuschuss der kostet 180
millionen euro nach ihren berechnungen
und es ist die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage die noch nicht entschieden
ist aber kommen soll die kostet in
diesem jahr
00 euro ein finanzierungsbedarf von 13
milliarden euro aber im topf sind
bereits jetzt 12,7 milliarden bis juli
wo sie es abschaffen wollen nach ihren
plänen wird mehr drin sein als das
überhaupt kostet es wird noch was
überzählig sein aber es sind in den in
den staatshaushalten in unserem
staatshaushalt sind mehreinnahmen über
die mehrwertsteuer sind mehreinnahmen
über den eu ets
zusammenrechnet dann kommt zehnmal mehr
sogar mehr als zehnmal mehr in den
staatshaushalt rein als sie mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss zurückgeben und
deshalb muss hier mehr gemacht werden
darauf dringen wir dafür haben wir
vorschläge gemacht die sind seriös und
es kommt zusammen und jetzige
herausforderung wir brauchen jetzt
entlastung und die grundsätzlichen
aufgaben auch die des klimaschutzes
bringen wir unter einen hut und dafür
arbeiten mit diesem parlament finden
sie wollte von andreas jung aus der
unionsfraktion wir konnten damit zum
vorletzten redner in dieser debatte
wobei auch später ist zum beispiel ja
auch noch um den heizkostenzuschuss geht
der hier
diskutiert werden soll das heißt doch da
wird es weiter um energiepreise gegen
carlos kaspar spd hat jetzt hier seine
erste rede in washington musste
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen seit
einigen monaten erleben wir eine
zunehmende teuerung heiz und stromkosten
steigen es zeigt sich dass sind die
haushalte mit geringem einkommen die
ganz besonders hart von diesen
entwicklungen betroffen sind wer ohnehin
schon wenig verdient den bleibt jetzt
noch weniger übrig nun hat die union
einen antrag vorgelegt der in seinen
titel ein großes versprechen anpreist
zeitnah wirksam und gerecht entlasten
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union mit einem gerechten
vorschlag hat den antrag leider gar
nichts zu tun
er gibt vor einkommensschwache haushalte
entlasten zu wollen tatsächlich aber
kommen ihre vorschläge insbesondere
unternehmen zugute für die
energieintensive industrie wollen sie
gleich zweimal tief in die tasche des
staatshaushaltes keiten sie fordern
nicht nur eine strom steuererstattung
sondern sogar noch zuschüsse große
unternehmen würden damit viel geld vom
staat bekommen sehr geehrte
unionsabgeordnete das ist nicht nur eine
sehr fragwürdige haushaltsplanung ihre
vorschläge sind auch überhaupt nicht
glaubwürdig machen wir uns doch mal
ehrlich dieser antrag ist geschrieben
für gutverdiener und unternehmen das ist
hier in der politik aber
schieben sie doch nicht dafür nicht die
haushalte mit geringem einkommen vor bei
einigen anderen punkten aus dem antrag
der union stimmen wir im ansatz über ein
klar wir müssen die erneuerbaren
energien weiter ausbauen um die
ökologische transformation weiter
voranzubringen das hätten wir aber auch
gemeinsam in der vergangenen legislatur
machen können da haben sie den
wirtschaftsminister gestellt und staaten
ständig auf der bremse
aber ich bin ja wirklich froh dass diese
fraktion jetzt wo sie in der opposition
ist endlich verstanden hat dass wir
massiv in die erneuerbaren energien
investieren müssen aber vielleicht
kommunizieren sie das auch an ihre
parteikolleginnen und kollegen vor ort
und herr jung jetzt bitte genau zuhören
da wo ich herkomme tut die cdu alles
dafür um die windkraft zu verhindern die
kreistagsfraktion im erzgebirge und
mittelsachsen wehren sich mit händen und
füßen gegen den ausbau gemeinsam mit der
kfd stimmen sie gegen windkraft herr
merz sieht so ihre brannten auch gegen
die ard aus ihre brandner aus nichts
weiter als ein kläglicher steinhaufen
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen der
union ja antrag in allen ehren aber sie
sind einfach nicht glaubwürdig im
gegensatz zur union setzen wir als ampel
koalition tatsächlich die energiewende
um heute wurde bereits ausgeführt wie
wir das schaffen und gleichzeitig
haushalte mit kleineren und mittleren
einkommen entlasten
ganz zentral ist und bleibt geschaffen
die eeg umlage ab nicht wie geplant 20
23 sondern schon in diesem jahr
außerdem werden wir den
heizkostenzuschuss erhöhen dies dieser
wird ja heute in erster lesung im
bundestag besprochen
liebe abgeordnete der cdu im gegensatz
zu ihnen wir machen seriöse politik die
wirkt auch für kleinere und mittlere
einkommen vielen dank
alles kostenlos für die spd hat hier wie
gesagt den
heizkostenzuschuss schon angesprochene
wird allerdings nicht erhöht sondern er
wird einmalig gezahlt für
bedürftige im sommer soll es dafür dann
geld geben genaueres erfahren wir
allerdings im
guten halben stunde dann ist dieser
tagesordnungspunkt an der reihe
sebastian schäfer spricht jetzt für
bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen wir
führen hier eine wichtige debatte in
einer sozialen marktwirtschaft und in
einer ökologisch sozialen
marktwirtschaft zumal darf nicht die
reinen marktlogik gelten wir müssen
immer auch die verteilungswirkung der
marktmechanismen im blick haben
und der fossile energie markt wie wir
ihn gerade haben ist eben extrem
angespannt im herbst 2009 10 haben wir
uns im vermittlungsverfahren zwischen
bund und ländern zum damaligen
klimapaket überparteilich verständigt
und als die union im vergangenen
frühjahr noch in verantwortung wahr da
gab es auch interessante vorstöße aus
ihren reihen frau präsidentin sie
gestatte mir ein zitat aus dem r n d als
konsequenz aus dem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zum
klimaschutzgesetz sollten die für 2022
und 20 23 geplanten anhebung schritte
auf 30 und 35 euro pro tonne co2
übersprungen werden forderte alexander
dobrindt er ist nicht mehr da vielmehr
wolle die csu im nächsten jahr direkt
einen sprung auf einen co2 preis von 45
euro machen der eigentliche erst 2024
vorlesen vorgesehen wäre bemerkenswert
für ihre partei
und schade wo sie jetzt mit ihrem antrag
hin gehen die absenkung der umsatzsteuer
die sie fordern hat eine völlig falsche
verteilungswirkung damit würden
vorrangig diejenigen entlastet werden
die einen hohen energieverbrauch haben
und das sind in unserem land in aller
regel diejenigen mit den höchsten
einkommen ich nenne sie mal pars pro
toto die dahlemer villenbesitzer und
ist es auch gar nicht garantiert dass
der preis dann gesenkt wird ja das hängt
wieder vom markt ab und auch die
erhöhung der pendlerpauschale die sie
vorschlagen wird regressiv hier werden
also diejenigen mit den höchsten
einkommen am meisten entlastet das hat
mit sozialer marktwirtschaft nichts zu
tun und geht an den nöten der unteren
einkommensschichten komplett vorbei
dieser antrag
zeigt noch einmal deutlich warum ein
politikwechsel in diesem land dringend
notwendig war in der letzten dekade
waren alle grundlagen da unser land
wirklich voranzubringen die
haushaltskonsolidierung ist ihnen nach
der finanzkrise mit der konjunktur
entwicklung und der lang andauernde
niedrigzinsphase in den schoß gefallen
in einem lang anhaltenden nullzinsphase
freien mitteln haben sie das geld
verpulvert für baukindergeld für
irgendwelche straßen in bayerischen
wahlkreisen unsere abhängigkeit von
russland könnte wesentlich geringer sein
wenn sie den ausbau der regenerativen
energien nicht abmontiert hätten und
diese passagen in ihrem antrag wirken
wie blanker hohn liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union die ampel geht
den fortschritt jetzt entschlossen an
natürlich hat die pandemie die situation
für uns nicht einfacher gemacht die
preise für fossile energien sind
deutlich angestiegen mehr habe es in der
debatte gehört wir müssen nun diejenigen
und gezielt unterstützen die am
stärksten von den steigenden preisen
betroffen sind das hat höchste priorität
wir haben einen heizkostenzuschuss
beschlossen und wir wollen die
mieterinnen und mieter mit einem
stufenmodell bei der co2 steuer
entlasten das hat die union in der
großen koalition verhindert werden die
eeg-umlage abschaffen wir geben das uns
anvertraute geld gezielt aus um unser
land zu stärken vielen dank
es schließt die aussprache und wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den antrag
der fraktionen der cdu/csu auf
drucksache 725 mit dem titel explosion
bei den energiepreisen bekämpfen zeitnah
wirksam und gerecht entlasten wer stimmt
für diesen antrag
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält ich
damit ist der antrag abgelehnt bei
zustimmung der einbringenden fraktionen
die auf die fraktion hat sich enthalten
die anderen fraktionen haben dagegen
gestimmt
interfraktionell wird überweisung der
vorlage auf drucksache 707 an der
tagesordnung aufgeführten ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen die federführung ist
jedoch strittig hier muss noch geklärt
werden welcher ausschuss sich
federführend mit den anträgen von der
afg und dann auch gleich von der
linksfraktion beschäftigt also ist es zb
er der finanzausschuss oder eher der
ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
während die abgeordneten darüber jetzt
noch entscheiden schauen wir schon mal
auf dem nächsten tagesordnungspunkt
da geht es um eine verlängerung der
sonderregelung beim kurzarbeitergeld in
der pandemie wurde ist ja wurden dort
bestimmte sonderregeln eingeführt dass
zum beispiel
das kurzarbeitergeld erhöht wird ab dem
vierten bezugsmonat bekommen diejenigen
die dieses kurzarbeitergeld bekommen 70
prozent des nettolohns ab dem siebten
monat 80 prozent das ist mehr als
normalerweise aber eben in der pandemie
hatte regierung das beschlossen dass die
person jetzt mehr kriegen und wenn wir
uns mal die zahlen anschauen dann sieht
man wie viel mehr personen
kurzarbeitergeld bekommen haben im
februar 2020 haben
184 1000 personen kurzarbeitergeld
bekommen und wenn wir das mal
vergleichen im april 2020 also zwei
monate später haben tatsächlich sechs
millionen personen kurzarbeitergeld
bekommen mittlerweile ist die zahl
zurückgegangen aber es gibt immer noch
viele menschen die darauf mit angewiesen
sind und deswegen haben hier die
koalitionsfraktionen einen gesetzentwurf
eingereicht dass eben diese
sonderregelung dass man mehr geld
bekommt um drei monate noch mal
verlängert wird bis zum 30 juni darüber
wird hier jetzt gleich diskutiert und
auch dann abgestimmt zu diesem
gesetzentwurf gibt es auch einen
entschließungsantrag der linksfraktion
auch der wird hier diskutiert denn auch
wenn das
von der linksfraktion
erst einmal
gutgeheißen wird dass diese regelung
verlängert wird fordert die
linksfraktion dass das kurzarbeitergeld
noch mal erhöht wird auf nämlich 90
prozent des nettolohns also dass die
person hier nochmal mehr bekommen der
erste redner in dieser debatte ist denn
auch bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil
den haben wir hier auch schon gesehen
ist jetzt auch wieder im bild der hier
natürlich diesen gesetzentwurf der
fraktionen verteidigen wird und für die
zustimmung für die abstimmung werden
wird jetzt wechseln noch einmal die
abgeordneten dem platz und dann kann es
hier auch gleich in der debatte losgehen
reise gehen würde ich gerne das wort
geben an den bundesminister hubertus
heil zur einbringen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
vor ziemlich genau zwei jahren habe ich
an diesem rednerpult anbeginn der korona
krise deutlich für die damalige
bundesregierung das gilt aber auch für
die heutige bundesregierung gemacht was
unser ziel am arbeitsmarkt ist unser
ziel ist es durch diese corona krise die
tiefste gesundheitskrise aber auch die
tiefste wirtschaftskrise unserer
generation den deutschen arbeitsmarkt
stabil und robust zu bringen und ich
kann feststellen vieles hat nicht
geklappt und dieser pandemie aber es ist
mit vereinten kräften gelungen den
deutschen arbeitsmarkt vor allen dingen
mit dem instrument der kurzarbeit stabil
zu halten die kurzarbeit war und ist die
stabilste brücke über ein tiefes
wirtschaftliches tal und ich bin dankbar
dass dieses verlangen diese region
dafür dass an anderer stelle auch
erwähnt ich war vor einem jahr
eingeladen
digital muss man leider sagen in amerika
ein arbeit wird ein austausch mit
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern über krisen reaktionen
in amerika und den usa auf der einen
seite und deutschland auf der anderen
seite am arbeitsmarkt und ich habe
festgestellt dass der begriff wird
kurzarbeit inzwischen im
angelsächsischen raum ein lehnwort
geworden ist
ähnlich wie das schöne deutsche worte
kindergarten und es steht als chiffre
für gutes krisenmanagement kurzarbeit
meine damen und herren hilft uns zum
einen arbeitsplätze zu sichern wir haben
in der korona krise über drei millionen
arbeitsplätze gesichert wir hatten
insgesamt acht millionen anträge zur
kurzarbeit es hilft aber auch
volkswirtschaft die
gesamtwirtschaftliche nachfrage zu
stabilisieren aber es hilft auch
unternehmen jetzt nach der krise mit
fachkräften an bord wieder durchstarten
zu können deshalb soll ich an dieser
stelle das dürfen wir nie vergessen es
war nicht nur wirtschaftshilfen sondern
es war der deutsche sozialstaat der
mitgeholfen hat dieses land stabil durch
diese schwierigen zeiten zu
und die haben meine damen und herren
kurzarbeit war und ist für unseren
sozialstaat sehr sehr teuer wir hatten
beginn der krise 26 milliarden euro
rücklagen bei der bundesagentur für
arbeit aus den guten zeiten wir haben
sie voll eingesetzt wir haben dann mit
steuermitteln nachgeholfen damit die
bundesagentur für arbeit stets
handlungsfähig ist ich sage ihnen aber
auch deutlich in solchen krisen muss man
unterscheiden kurzarbeit verteuert aber
die rückkehr von massenarbeitslosigkeit
zuzulassen wäre für deutschland
wirtschaftlich und sozial viel viel
teurer gewesen deshalb war das der
richtige weg und wir setzen ihn heute
vor
will aber auch für die bundesregierung
erklären dass unser ziel nicht erst
kurzarbeit vorher war sondern wir bauen
brücken und wollen das andere ufer
erreichen wir haben die hoffnung dass
wir im sommer in eine situation ist aber
wir haben nach wie vor branchen die
schwer getroffen sind vor allen dingen
veranstaltungsgebäude im messebau in der
gastronomie diese unternehmen brauchen
und die beschäftigten brauchen jetzt die
kurzarbeit im industriellen bereich
haben wir auch mit problemen hin und
wieder zu tun obwohl die industrie sehr
sehr gut läuft stichwort lieferketten
problem also deshalb bin ich dankbar
dass dieser deutsche bundestag heute die
brücke weiter verlängert ich bin
übrigens auch der opposition der
vernünftigen opposition dankbar dass sie
den schritt vergrößert kürzungen zu
bestimmt hat und offensichtlich heute
auch mitmachen will liebe kolleginnen
kollegen aber es ist wichtig dass wir
diesen weg gehen im einzelnen wir
verlängern jetzt auch noch mal die
bezugsdauer von 24 auf 28 monate weil
wenn man zurück rechnet 24 monate seit
beginn der krise für viele beschäftigten
sonst zu einer abbruchkante geführt
haben und wir haben die hoffnung dass
wir im sommer in einer besseren
situation sind wir verlängern die
sogenannte treppe für diejenigen die
ganz lange drin sind und aufgrund der
tatsache dass in vielen bereichen keine
aufschläge gezahlt werden 60 oder 67
prozent familien oft die geringe
verdienen sind ziemlich harte nummer
sind und deshalb ist es richtig dass wir
dafür sorgen dass für diejenigen die
lange drin sind es auch ein puffer gibt
bis hin zu 80 87 prozent meine damen und
herren richtig ist auch dass wir uns
eine verordnungsermächtigung
gestorben und ich bin dem parlament sehr
dankbar dass sie das unterstützen und im
fall der fälle dass im sommer nicht gut
läuft aus welchen gründen auch immer wir
haben ja eine unkalkulierbare pandemie
auch kurzfristig noch reagieren zu
können ich hoffe allerdings dass wir
davon nicht gebrauch machen müssen ich
will das ja auch sagen weil wir haben
einen schritt gemacht er in einigen
bereichen kritisiert wurde wir sind mit
der sozialversicherungsbeiträge schon
zum ersten januar von 100 auf 50 prozent
runter und wir gehen jetzt von 50 auf
null ich halte das auch für vertretbar
zumal wirtschaftshilfen haben auch aus
dem bereich des kollegen habeck und weil
übrigens 20 50 prozent holen kann wenn
man denn als unternehmen kurzarbeit mit
qualifizierung und weiterbildung
verknüpfen kann und ich will auch sagen
wir müssen auf die kasse ein bisschen
gucken denn die bundesagentur für arbeit
muss rücklagen aufbauen für spätere
krisensituationen und für die großen
aufgaben der transformation in bezug auf
die qualifizierung
aber sehr dankbar dass sie diesen weg
heute gehen auch mit fristverkürzung sie
helfen damit vielen beschäftigten in
deutschland sie helfen unternehmen und
bei allem was nicht läuft wir können in
deutschland vielleicht auch mal stolz
sein auf die dinge die funktionieren die
kurzarbeit hat funktioniert das ist
nicht allein das verdienst der
bundesregierung oder meines ministeriums
oder dieses parlaments sondern es ist
vor allen dingen das verdienst der
fleißigen kolleginnen kollegen der
bundesagentur für arbeit die das
vorbildlich umgesetzt haben die ganze
zeit deshalb gilt mein bewusste
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter in den
jobcentern und bundesagentur für arbeit
die deutschland wirklich durch diese
krise geholfen waren herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
soweit also die leitung von
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil auf
den folgten stephan stracke der sprecher
für arbeit und soziales der
unionsfraktion
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
auch in der gegenwärtigen lage der
pandemie ist die ist der vereinfachte
zugang zur kurzarbeit über den 31 märz
hinaus notwendig und auch ohne zweifel
richtig und der fristverkürzung bitte
minister sind wir natürlich gerne
nachgekommen die unterstützen als
oppositionsfraktion immer dort wo es
notwendig ist aber erlauben sie mir ein
bisschen hat es mich doch erstaunt die
mangelnde umsicht und vorausschau weil
der datum des 31 märz war doch allseits
in diesem bereich tatsächlich bekannt
dass die gegenwärtigen regelungen hier
auslaufen aber entscheidend ist das was
sie vorlägen und das was sie vorliegen
ist nicht ausreichend um beschäftigung
zu sichern und damit auch die
unternehmen in den kurzarbeitenden
branchen in ihrem mit ihren fachkräften
halten zu können
ich fordere sie aufbessern sie nach und
verlängern sie für drei monate die
bisherigen regelungen für den hälftigen
ersatz der sozialversicherungsbeiträge
und beziehen sie auch die zeitarbeit in
die regelung zur kurzarbeit mit ein
die dauer der pandemie und die damit
verbundenen einschränkungen haben viele
branchen finanziell belastet wenn ist
der harz erwähnt besonders hotel und
gaststättenbereich der einzelhandel dass
die veranstaltungswirtschaft der
messebau insbesondere auch das
verarbeitende gewerbe hat zum teil
probleme was lieferengpässe angeht und
in diesen branchen an diesen betrieben
sind die rücklagen und die liquidität
vielfach aufgebraucht und das stellen
sie ja selber fest beispielsweise in
ihrer begründung hinsichtlich der
eilbedürftigkeit ich darf zitieren es
gibt eine größere zahl von betrieben die
seit beginn der pandemie im märz 2020
kurzarbeit beziehen und bei denen die
maximale bezugsdauer ende februar 20 22
ausläuft aufgrund der dauer der pandemie
ist davon auszugehen dass diese betriebe
über keine ausreichende
liquiditätsreserven mehr verfügen die
betriebe sind also auf eine nahtlose
bewilligung von kurzarbeitergeld
angewiesen zitat ende und das bedeutet
natürlich auch die weitere erstattung
der sozialversicherungsbeiträge in höhe
von 50 prozent wenn keine ausreichende
liquidität vorhanden ist dann ist das
der notwendige weitere sprit schritt sie
springen zu kurz und gefährden auch den
letzten meter der hoffentlich endenden
pandemie ohne not arbeitsplätze das ist
aus unserer sicht der falsche weg den
sie an dieser stelle hier beschreiten
und die sachverständigenanhörung hat ja
ein ganz klares und eindeutiges ergebnis
in diesem bereich gezeigt unisono
wirtschaft und gewerkschaften sehen es
als notwendig an dass hier auch die
beiträge weiterhin erstattet werden
folgen sie dem rat der sachverständigen
und tun sie das richtige und auch der
hinweis auf die qualifizierung der
minister getan hat ja natürlich schon
richtig qualifizierung ist überall gut
aber auch qualifizierung kostet geld und
wenn man sie ernst nehmen will ihre
argumentation was die liquidität angeht
dann funktioniert es nicht und dann ist
es auch kein praxistaugliches
instrumentarium das angenommen wird von
der praxis auch darauf haben die
sachverständigen
einstimmig hingewiesen also das
instrument der qualifizierung ist kein
praxistaugliches mittel zur
beschäftigungssicherung in der
gegenwärtigen lage und deswegen ist auch
der hinweis zu kurz gesprungen in diesem
bereich und auch was die aussicht auf
öffnung schritte angeht seien an der
stelle nur erwähnt auch das wird
natürlich
verbesserungen bringen aber bis die es
ankommt in den betroffenen betriebe
denken sie beispielsweise an den
messebau dauert dies doch wirklich
ziemlich lange und es ist vor allem auch
nicht nachvollziehbar warum sie die
zeitarbeitskräfte nicht den zugang zur
kurzarbeit gewähren beschäftigte in der
zeitarbeit sind keine beschäftigten
zweiter klasse auch sie haben es
verdient hier wie andere gleich
behandelt zu werden und der deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund habe dies auch klar
und deutlich zum ausdruck gebracht und
das sollte für sie gerade von der spd
umsetzungs auftrag sein tun sie das
richtige und verändern sie das was not
tut nämlich eine heftige einbeziehung
der sozialversicherungsbeiträge und
natürlich die einbeziehung schiller zeit
leicht sauer reicht uns was abziehen
gerade noch im gang kritiker
zu ihrer ersten rede hat jetzt die
kollegin tina winkelmann das wort für
bündnis 90 die grünen
man sitzt im ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen wir
folgen dem rat der sachverständigen und
deswegen verlängern wird es ist freitag
und deshalb passt es hervorragend dass
wir heute über dieses thema sprechen wir
wissen doch alle was es heißt dass
freitag ist es ist wochenende wissen sie
noch wir sind nach einer arbeitswoche
auf veranstaltungen in die kneipe in die
clubs ein kurztrip übers wochenende
wir konnten abschalten energie tanken
und freuten uns die ganze woche auf ein
konzert ein theaterstück auf kultur auf
veranstaltungen auf einen schafkopf auf
gastlichkeit für viele ging die arbeit
dann erst richtig los und jetzt immer im
gastgewerbe im gastgewerbe und in der
veranstaltungsbranche viele wichtige
jobs hängen genau hier dran und die
hätten wir mit der kurzarbeit die kultur
die kultur will ihren hunger nach
wirkung stellen und wir hunger nach
kultur hier braucht es
arbeitsplatzsicherung sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen die redezeit
reicht eben nicht aus um auf alle
bereiche explizit einzugehen die unsere
hilfe brauchen und von uns durch die
verlängerung des kurzarbeitergeldes auch
bekommen einen wichtigen bereich will
und muss ich aber nennen es ist die
pflege denn mit der verlängerung wird
sichergestellt dass die vereinbarkeit
von pflege und beruf weiter bestehen
bleibt ein wichtiger pfeiler unseres
miteinander ist diese vereinbarkeit und
daher wird die bundesregierung die
regelungen im pflegezeitgesetz und
familien pflegezeit über den 1 märz
hinaus verlängern
liebe bürgerinnen und bürger ich weiß
selber was es heißt schicht arbeiterin
auf kurzarbeit zu sein
2008 habe ich selber kurzarbeitergeld
bezogen und ja ich und meine damaligen
kolleginnen und kollegen waren froh
diese großartige sicherung zu haben
der minister hat es eben angesprochen
kindergarten rucksack realpolitik sind
deutsche begriffe die den weg in die
englische sprache gefunden haben
gleiches galt für das wort kurzarbeit
dieses wort 20 eben gleich zu beginn der
pandemie und der dadurch entstandenen
wirtschaftlichen turbulenzen im
angloamerikanischen raum wieder dies
zeigt was für ein erfolg dieses
instrument zur bekämpfung von
arbeitslosigkeit ist es wurde
mittlerweile vielfach auf der welt
kopiert und ist neben der dualen
ausbildung ein absolutes erfolgsmodell
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
kurzarbeit hat vor einem 1 verhindert
massenarbeitslosigkeit der hochstand
wurde im sommer 2020 mit 6 millionen
beschäftigten erreicht und wir können
mit wissenschaftlichen wetter und sagen
wir haben damit millionen jobs eben
erhalten kolleginnen und kollegen die
kritik am schnellen verfahren kann ich
teilweise verstehen eine ausreichende
beratungszeit ist wichtig und dafür
stehen wir ja auch nur hier brauchen die
unternehmen und die beschäftigten
planungssicherheit
es ist eine nahtlose bewilligung von
kurzarbeitergeld lieben hier notwendig
wo wir wofür wir den rechtlichen rahmen
mit der verlängerung setzten unser dank
geht ihm hier an durch sachverständige
stücken an die sachverständigen die ihre
expertise hier eingebracht haben und an
die fraktionen damit wir die schnell auf
den weg bringen können es pressiert
und weil es pressiert verlängern wie ein
bewährtes bestehendes instrument und
machen kein neues thema auf und deshalb
das schnelle verfahren
es wird die maximale bezugsdauer ab 28
monate verlängert dies war eben unter
anderem eine forderung die mich und sie
in mehreren zuschriften immer wieder
erreicht hat es bleibt auch bei den
vereinfachten zugang erleichterungen und
minijobs bleiben anrechnungsfrei diese
antworten brauchen die arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer und wir liefern sie
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
warum machen wir das hier warum
debattieren wir hier heute es sind die
menschen die uns verdeutlichen dass die
verlängerung des kurzarbeitergeldes
gebraucht wird es ist ein unterschied ob
jemand sagt ich bin arbeitslos oder ich
bin in kurzarbeit es ist ein unterschied
ob jemand sagt ich weiß nicht wie es
machen soll oder ich kann pflege und
beruf vereinen es geht um harald sabine
jahre keiner jubi und gitte es geht um
menschen und die haben nahmen deshalb
verlängern wir das kurzarbeitergeld
nicht bedanke mich wäre nutzen können
[Applaus]
das wäre natürlich nicht interessant
absoluten bei diesem namen an
persönliche bekannte gedacht hat sie
sich auswärts
hui spricht als nächste auch sie ist wie
die vorrednerin mitglied im ausschuss
für arbeit und soziales
die regierung will das kurzarbeitergeld
noch einmal um drei monate bis ende juni
verlängert
warum war in deutschland immer noch der
pandemie status gilt und nach ansicht
der regierung wohl auch in drei monaten
noch gelten soll warum sonst diese
erstaunliche verlängerung es sind im
wesentlichen menschen im dax gehört
handel event und kulturbetrieb die wegen
2g und 3g in kurzarbeit sind fast eine
halbe million von ihnen schon über seit
zwei jahren viele sogar in kurzarbeit
null das heißt sie sind de facto
arbeitslos würde man die kurzarbeit
nicht mehr verlängern wäre schlagartig
eine beitrag halbe million menschen
offiziell arbeitslos
zusätzlich zu den stand heute 2,5
millionen arbeitslosen oder wenn man
ehrlich zählt und die unterbeschäftigt
mit einrechnet sind es ja tatsächlich
3,2 millionen arbeitslosen das sind sehr
sehr viele menschen die fast alle
arbeiten wollen aber nicht können weil
es keine arbeit für sie gibt und
es werden noch mehr werden so sehr sich
die regierung auch gemüt dies durch
gesetze zu verschleiern denn gesetze
schaffen keine arbeit nur die wirtschaft
als unternehmen und selbstständige
schaffen arbeit dies wird ihnen aber
extrem erschwert durch die pandemische
gerne lungs maßnahmen oder haben sie
angst meine damen und herren von der
regierungskoalition
dass sie ohne pandemie verlängerung ihre
impfpflicht nicht mehr argumentieren
können ihre planungen
die von ihnen als ungeimpfte
stigmatisierten menschen wollen aber
nicht geimpft werden sie gehen seit
wochen zu 100000 über die auf die straße
übrigens zusammen mit vielen geimpften
um ihnen genau das zu zeigen
und sie wollen sie trotzdem wird eine
impfung zwingen warum den pandemie
verlauf können sie damit nicht ändern
sie ruinieren damit sehenden auges
unsere wirtschaft
während überall in den ländern um uns
herum geöffnet und gelockert würden
bleiben sie mit ihrer impfpflicht plane
weiter auf geisterfahrer kurs
das ergebnis während überall um uns
herum die wirtschaft wieder wächst ist
sie in deutschland im letzten quartal
einfach ein ganzes prozent geschrumpft
die reallöhne sind ebenfalls gesunken
wenn sie diesen weg weitergehen fahren
die deutschland in die rezession
daher fordere ich sie auf beenden sie
endlich den pandemie status schaffen sie
alle regelungen ab und lassen sie die
wirtschaft wieder masten frei laufen das
erspart nicht nur den sozialkassen wohl
volk so weiter kosten sondern sie geben
den menschen auch ein positives signal
und sagen ihnen ihr könnt wieder euren
berufen nachgehen ihr könnt alle
geschäfte wieder unbegrenzt betreiben
euch wieder unbedrängt miteinander
treffen vergnügen und wieder ein ganz
normales leben führen nach eiern
persönlichen geschmack
frau kollegin koma gefallen und herren
sie alle hier vertreten die bürger
unseres landes geben sie ihnen endlich
ihre freiheit zurück danke
er hat wohin war das für die fdp
fraktion hat hier ein geisterfahrer kurs
kritisiert auch sie vierten pascal kober
der sprecher für arbeitsmarkt- und
sozialpolitik der fdp fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir freuen uns
dass wir die verlängerung der
sonderregelung beim kurzarbeitergeld
beschließen können wenn ich mich
ausdrücklich bedanken bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen der fraktionen
cdu/csu und linke dass sie den frist
verzichten zugestimmt haben dass sie
konstruktiv hiermit die regelungen
schnell auf den weg gebracht haben das
zeigt dass unser parlament
reaktionsschnell ist das zeigt dass
unser parallel parlamentarismus auch in
kürze handlungsfähig ist ein gutes
zeichen dafür möchte ich mich
ausdrücklich bedanken
die der verlängerung beschreiben wir
letztlich mehrere perspektiven zum einen
die wirtschaftliche lage und die
situation auf dem arbeitsmarkt haben
sich spürbar verbessert
das ist gut aber noch nicht für alle
betriebe und branchen gleichermaßen bei
der reihe von unternehmen hat sich in
den letzten wochen abgezeichnet dass sie
noch über den 31
märz sie daraus auf das kurzarbeitergeld
angewiesen sein werden insbesondere die
veranstaltungsbranche und die
gastwirtschaft kämpfen mit den
auswirkungen und der ausbreitung von
omikron und mit der tatsache dass die
impfquote weiterhin hinter dem
wünschenswerten zurückbleibt für diese
unternehmen sind die wir heute zu
beschließenden verlängerungen der
möglichkeiten des erleichterten zugangs
zum kurzarbeitergeld die chance
unverzichtbare mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter zu halten
dass die unternehmen in not sind ist
nicht ihre verantwortung sondern den
einschränkenden staatlichen maßnahmen
geschuldet und an der stelle möchte ich
mich auch ganz ausdrücklich einmal bei
den unternehmerinnen unternehmen
bedanken
die über das kurzarbeitergeld hinaus
durch eigene leistungen den sogenannten
remanenzkosten
die solidarität mit ihren mitarbeitern
und mitarbeitern mitgetragen haben das
war ein tolles signal und dafür
ausdrücklichen dank von dieser stelle
aus
gleichzeitig wollen wir perspektivisch
aus dem krisenmodus auch aussteigen und
zur normalität wieder zurückkehren das
betrifft natürlich die einschränkungen
den maßnahmen die wir zurücknehmen
wollen und das betrifft aber auch
mittelfristig die sonne regelungen zur
kurzarbeit aus diesen müssen wir in
absehbarer zeit verantwortungs bus
wieder herauskommen wir haben jetzt noch
mal um drei monate verlängert mit der
option einer weiteren verlängerung durch
eine verordnungsermächtigung
aber die bundesregierung sollte dieses
mittel äußerst verantwortungsbewusst
einsetzen kurzarbeit darf und kann kein
dauer instrument sein wir müssen
vermeiden dass strukturelle probleme
einer branche durch das kurzarbeitergeld
verdeckt werden und das notwendige
anpassung und in nicht zukunftsfähige
unternehmen
verbleiben
wir müssen zur kenntnis nehmen dass
viele unternehmen derzeit auch im
aufwachsen begriffen sind und
händeringend mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter suchen und dass der verbleib
in dem einen unternehmen für den
einzelnen durchaus sicherheit bedeutet
und erstrebenswert ist in manchen fällen
aber auch damit ein nachteil für ein
anderes unternehmen einher geht und
vielleicht eine chance für den einzelnen
mittelfristig verloren geht deshalb
müssen wir daran denken dass kurzarbeit
kein dauer instrument sein kann wir
müssen da auch daran denken dass die
ausgaben für das kurzarbeitergeld
finanziert werden müssen für die zukunft
glaube ich dass wir lernen müssen dass
die qualifizierung nicht in dem maße
stattgefunden hat wie er ist für gut
gefunden hätten und dass wir daraus für
die zukunft lernen müssen wenn wir
kurzarbeit mit qualifizierung gemeinsam
verbinden wollen was muss besser werden
in zukunft das bleibt eine aufgabe aus
diesen erfahrungen und auch denen
sollten wir uns stellen
das kurzarbeitergeld ist eine
erfolgsgeschichte
aber nichts ist so gut dass es nicht
auch noch verbessert werden könnte
vielen dank liebe kolleginnen und